[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
yeah
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so excited to spend my birthday here
together with you guys our excellent uh
chess experts in the studio Grandmaster
David Howell International Master Tanya
Sexton and Grandmaster Robert has and oh
Robert yesterday what a day especially
winners final with Magnus Carlsen and
Hikaru Nakamura what did you take away
from that it was epic and it was Mind
Games some tricks by Magnus Carlsen they
seemed to be in Hikaru nakamura's head
that bid one second apart that was
fantastic and today it's all about
getting that second spot in tomorrow's
Grand Final to meet Magnus Carlsen who
do you think will take that final spot
it is going to be a tough match for both
these players now Wesley against Arjun
is what we start with of course on paper
it's easy to say that Wesley is a
favorite but do not underestimate Arjun
he has shown that on a good day he can
beat the very best players he has been
informed the only one so far in this
event to have beaten Magnus Carlsen uh
and I think he has played phenomenally
well so far he needs to come in again
with that same Precision try and get
Wesley in messy situations create a
Chaos on the board because if it's a
strategic positional fight
can't imagine a player like Wesley going
down in that so Arjun needs to do what
he does best and take it up a notch wow
oh that's going to be interesting and
yesterday David we had a lot of fun as
well are you getting a lot of messages
about Pokemon that's all I'm getting the
inbox was full this morning Kaya but uh
yeah go team Pikachu yeah that's your
favorite uh Snorlax
well Magnus Carlsen he has a day off
today actually because he's already
ready for the Grand Final and Magnus
he's in Canada visiting the chess brass
he did post a picture on Instagram
simply doing what I enjoy and enjoying
myself and Tonya do you think this is
just what Magnus likes the most in the
sports club playing chess being with
friends he loves it having a good time
playing chess that is life goals and
Magnus having a good time there and
that's when he plays his best chess as
well is that showing David that Magnus
is actually really enjoying himself now
it really is he's not necessarily
hitting his highest levels but he's
doing enough and you can see on the
board he's very relaxed he's not putting
too much pressure on himself and
especially in these long online
tournaments where it's a real grind it's
a real psychological battle not just
with your opponents but also with
yourself uh yeah he's somehow getting
the results he needs he definitely is
and today it's all about getting that
final spot in tomorrow's Grand Final
yesterday we had some epic battles one
of of them was between the two young
Indians Arjun aragaisi and yukash
this is his final shot yeah it's just
played King's F1 forgetting that
castling is legal in chess I think his
idea is to keep the Rook on the h-file
to attack is just telling Arjun you are
not castling and if you do I am going to
attack your king wow
he Retreats his Knight to the
small Bishop takes Rook it takes Bishop
it's brilliant it's over good cash is
knocked out of the tournament Arjun Eric
icy makes it through oh there we go it
started this is the winner is final it
goes for the more ambitious approach wow
that is making intentions very clear
shots fired very surprised I've got to
say that Hikaru looks so poker faced on
the camera because I would be terrified
here for black how do you get that white
porn it must be so frustrating Hikaru
knows he's about to make a draw and
finally we see it wow here we go look at
Magnus he quickly responds with Knight
F6 challenging that Rook on its place
and now that Rook is really oddly placed
are we gonna see a repetition again are
we gonna see Bishop B3 Queen F5 Bishop
C2 it is happening we are heading to arm
again
we've got liftoff
yes because there's a tactic Knight
takes Pawn on E5 that is a game changer
oh he does doesn't find it he moves his
Knight away look at the evaluation bar
dropping down in Black's favor those are
two Runners and Hikaru is he going to
try and flag Magnus the answer is no
it's a draw hey Cara is actually the one
who after the draw that's the ultimate
sign of respect that is a good show of
sportsmanship reminders Carlson wins the
winner finals with a draw
a smile on Magnus Carlson's face and
also in the studio to guide us through
this day for in the air things monster
is international Master Ivanka houseka
and he did seem happy yesterday winning
that match against Hikaru but Banks
actually said in an interview that uh he
wasn't too happy with the way they both
played the winner I mean he he basically
said that you know he struggled actually
at finding a few resources you know he
even said that there was a resource that
he should never ever missed in a million
years and he actually said that the best
ever best move in that match was
actually predicting the time for the
Armageddon he's only called it a soul
read and of course Magnus bidding eight
minutes 58 Hikaru bidding 8 minutes 59
so the big battle to get the black
pieces in Armageddon and uh well Hikaru
definitely he will have to wait because
he has to meet today's Victor over was
the Wesley so and Arden aragaisy yep hey
Cara Nakamura is playing later today we
also had a loser's bracket yesterday and
we can take a look at the results on
the losers bracket the first it was uh
Lutheran Sports finals Arjun Eric icy
knocked out go cash that was an intense
battle they played some fantastic games
these two youngsters yeah and I really
like the way that Arjun aragaisy
actually approached that you know he
came very well prepared and he decided
just to take it into some kind of messy
position where gkash just couldn't
navigate the complications so he looked
very strong and Wesley so just looked
powerful I mean he's been unbeaten in
this tournament he was also unbeaten
when he won the title Tuesdays twice
actually something that only Hikaru
Nakamura has done wow and yeah I have to
say Wesley looking very impressive and I
agree with what Tanya said earlier Arjun
really has to follow in his role models
footsteps that's Gary Kasparov and try
to mix it up come with some fighting
spirit and aggression yeah Magnus
Carlsen has actually lost a game in the
air things monster to our generator guys
he is ready for the Grand Final Hikaru
and Wesley playing now on the losers
bracket they haven't lost the game yet
no they haven't noticed yet it seems a
bit unfair actually but such are the
rules of Armageddon chess yeah and uh
where a draw is insufficient if you're
playing with the white pieces yeah
We are following
um division one today but there is also
division two and division three going on
in the air things monsters and these are
today's uh games coming up in division
two there's a winners final with
two fantastic players Fabiano caruana is
fighting today what do you expect from
the winners finally here Ivanka this is
going to be a very interesting battle
because actually traditionally Fabi
hasn't actually been very good at speed
chess but he has been working on that in
recent years and then we have you Yang
Yi who has a very creative style and
actually if you were to look at their
head to head it's actually you Yang Yi
who it has the Battle of him Fabiano and
we also noticed another big name in
division two still in their fighting
former world champion Vladimir kramnik
edible I know I mean I I he's like my
personal favorite you know it's so great
to have a former world champion fighting
and there's also someone who is slightly
older than their counterparts you know
it really is great to have such a role
model playing and doing so well but you
know he does have a tough path ahead of
him this is not the final step he has
three matches to go he has to win three
in order to get to the Grand Final
that's a big ass yeah
but division three will be decided today
actually the Grand Final is coming up
today and it is between these two Sam
Savion against Prague
it would actually feel like Groundhog
Day for these two because I actually
played them each other in the winners
bracket and it was Sam sauvian who won
in this hundred move Armageddon it was
that close and of course he knocked down
pregnant down it kind of felt like a
game of snakes and ladders there and
Prague had to work his way back up there
and it's going to be tense it's going to
be very very close Sam Sabian starts off
with the white pieces and that's very
critical in these two matching counters
yeah let's take a look at what they are
fighting for this is the price Fund in
the air things Masters a total of 235
000 in all three divisions and remember
the winner of division two not only gets
ten thousand dollars and 50 tour points
the winner also qualifies for the next
first division event in the Champions
chess tour
and uh
we're gonna follow from the start here
division one it's gonna be the losers
semi-final coming up Wesley so is
fighting to go all the way to the losers
final to meet tikara Nakamura and Wesley
so
he has some big goals coming up in 2023
your top three goals that you hope to
achieve in 2023 let's see the first one
would be to qualify to the candidates
I've only played in the candidates once
and it didn't go very well in 2018
so I'm very excited to see what 2023
holds uh there will be some over the
board tournaments here and there but
almost half of the tournaments are held
online and they're very important they
got a lot of stakes I'm very pleased to
win last year's the global chess
tournament I'm excited to be part of the
new championchester and chess.com it
interesting thing with this new
partnership will will hold for them win
some big online tournaments that would
be very nice for me as a player I'm
trying to balance myself between being
very good at classical well of doing
that bad online and speeches because
they're two they're very different
things and so this year is going to be
exciting as well as a challenge and my
calendar is actually getting very full
at the moment I also need time to spend
between resting recovering and also
preparing and number three would be
too ambitious but now it's a
reach the top three
let's go right now is to reach the
loser's final to face the car Nakamura
he's up against Arjun erag icy and
the player that wins this match between
Wesley and Arjun the player that reaches
the losers final is actually guaranteed
a spot in the next first division event
in the air things monster do you think
that's something that is maybe
especially for Wesley in the back of his
head heading into this match yeah I
think for Wesley so he was given
automatic entry into this one he wants
to earn himself a chance once more and
he sees this as an opportunity to face
off against the car Nakamura he wants
that rematch I think Wesley he's trying
to earn his place in that Grand Final
yeah who do you hold as a favorite in
this match David well I'm gonna have to
go with the experience I'm gonna have to
say Wesley so even though I am arjun's
biggest fan as I said yesterday not many
people have rushed me
I think it's going to be very close
there's a lot at stake that first
division spot for the next tournament
but whoever wins is gonna have to run
the gauntlet anyway imagine facing
Hikaru next then having to face Magnus
in the final and having to beat Magnus
twice whoever gets there uh what a
Herculean Tusk yeah it's best out of two
games in the losers semi-final if
I'll go to Armageddon and Wesley and the
Arjun they're sitting basically on
opposite sides of the world it's quite
early in the morning for Wesley so in
Minnesota Arjun late at night playing in
India and what will it take for Arjun
today Tanya to beat Wesley and make it
to the losers final
he has to have a lot of energy for
today's match now Wesley is perhaps the
hottest player on the circuit to beat he
is super duper solid and I'm a big fan
of Wesley I mean how can you not be the
guy he's just probably one of the
kindest chess players and on the Beast
he's just I mean on the board he's an
absolute Beast he just doesn't lose any
games
again what I said earlier Kaya it's
really important for Arjun to stick to
his style today he needs to get those
Dynamic positions the kind which is just
filled with landmines you know everyone
and anyone can go wrong and that's why
he has his best chance against uh Wesley
he needs to believe that he can beat him
they played together at the top of Steel
chess India rapid and Blitz and in fact
Arjun with the white pieces did get a
win against Wesley in the blitz section
and the other two games were a draw so
in speeches I think he does have that
confidence that he can do it that said
it's so hard to bet against someone like
Wesley yeah definitely
10 years separate these two players
Wesley so playing for the US and Argent
and Argosy playing for India ranked at
number eight and 38 in the world in
classical chess and Wesley we call him
so solid all the time Robert Arjun we've
seen him sacrifice pieces is there just
two very different styles up against
each other here completely different
styles clashing today because Wesley so
in the last classical event he says he
wants to focus on his classical chess he
had two wins and nine draws our generic
geissy played more Fighting Chess
throughout the Tata steel Masters he
ended up with five losses and no wins to
his name it was a bad event he could put
that in the past but Arjun he's
typically very combative Wesley he wants
to keep things nice and steady okay and
he starts off with the white pieces
Wesley so best out of two rapid games if
they are tied it will be decided in
Armageddon the time control is 15
minutes plus three seconds increment and
we have started we have liftoff it's a
Kingsport opening Wesley has gone for
the Italian game several times already
ready this tournament including twice
against Hikaru Nakamura didn't lead him
anywhere we've got to say he's also
doubled with the Spanish with which
opening will he choose slightly ought to
see him pause there but just finding his
bearings and there we go it's the
Spanish maybe not predicting E5 from
Arjun today Arjun does play every
opening imaginable uh so let's start to
this one yeah Wesley's gone for the
Spanish and of course Arjun
bad for this
I think it is an advantage to Wesley to
start with the white pieces uh with two
games and the reason for that is of
course because he has the higher seating
in the tournament but in a two-game
match imagine starting with the white
pieces if you're able to create your
chances and get that win Arjun just has
one more game to strike back and he
plays with black that too so that is a
really difficult spot to be in Arjun
needs to make sure that things don't go
too wrong in this one he has to
neutralize that edge because a player
like Wesley you give him one opportunity
you know he doesn't maybe go for the
most dynamic options on the board but
he's that player who makes the most of a
mistake that the opponent does so if
Arjun slips even slightly today Wesley
will grab it with both hands and not
give Arjun a chance this is a super
important game because I think for Arjun
starting with black he has to be really
careful in this one and it's just really
really focused the whole day he cannot
let his mind go anywhere
absolutely Kaya but I you know we look
at Arjun on the camera and it almost
appears as if he's just gotten out of
bed he's got that classic I don't care
Arjun pose going on yeah but let me tell
you that is just deceptive the guy is
super focused right now he knows that he
needs to get this job done to play that
match against Hikaru and he knows he's
up against one of the finest in the
world they're kind of they kind of look
uh the same the way they're sitting
right is this a very typical chess
player pose just leaning uh supporting
the big brains that they both have and
because before the game we saw Arjun
checking the air quality maybe checking
the aircon but uh I want to praise his
hair quality in this game like uh like
Tanya said uh yeah just got out of bed
look just looking really chilled out and
uh that has brought him luck so far but
uh meanwhile it's a variation we call
the anti-martial uh where white doesn't
allow a Gambit that we saw yesterday
between uh Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus
Carlsen and instead a set of Bishops are
off the board black does have a set of
double pawns uh in the center on the
e-file but other than that everything
else looks balance Robin and I always
like to say when there are double pawns
it means they're open files and that
Rook The castled Rook it is open along
the f file that could spell some trouble
for the white king at some point but
right now west is keeping the position
locked up zero pawns have been traded
it's becoming a strategic battle in the
early stages but white really would like
to do is trade those Queens if you could
pluck them off the board we get into a
queenless middle game where White's Pawn
structure nice and healthy and blacks
contracts are a little bit compromised
so it's a long battle that we're about
to see take fold yeah a long battle and
uh we will see these slightly mysterious
Maneuvers such as arjun's last move just
shuffling that Rook across maybe hinting
that that Rook will jump down the board
later on to go for White's lone a pawn
uh that a pawn is an intruder in the
black camp and that could be a real
weakness later but first Wesley breaks
in the center he's not happy to just sit
around and wait he uh asks questions of
arjun's Center those that massive black
pawns there and after black just reacts
defending holding everything together he
does develop his Queen so a clear threat
on the board for the first time really
in this game White's Queen is eyeing up
a Target that black apron so on the
diagonal threat how does Arjun Parry
this one well as you're pointing out one
of the ideas that black has is to step
up with The Rook all the way to B5 and
that's the point of getting the Rook to
this well seemingly blocked file you
really want to Target that weakness on
A5 which has shifted so far away from
the friendly B Pawn on B2 now that's one
way that you can defend A6 and put
pressure the other idea that black has
in these kind of positions David is with
the last knight move the retreating
right night move it might look passive
but it's only retreated to go forward
eventually you can already gobble up on
D4 which I see is what arjun's gone for
and after all the trades in the center
that Knight on D7 will in fact jump up
on the board over to C5 got that A6 pawn
and put pressure on the E4 Pawn I like
how arjuns handle the opening so far
yeah again a profit both of you in this
tournament you're predicting the future
really really well this has happened and
Arjun does have a very nice night here
holding everything together Wesley
meanwhile needs to get these pieces to
start working and black has more sexual
pawns there's one tactical note and the
reason why origin uh played this line is
that Wesley his last move was Knight
takes Pawn on D4 he had the option of
taking the A6 Pawn if we just go back a
turn here but that would have allowed a
potentially devastating exchange
sacrifice Rook takes Knight on F3
exposing the white king there are not
many Defenders on that flank so for that
outside pass Pawn that white has on A5
that looks great the king is in some
serious danger the queen and the Knight
ready to hop in and attack the white
king and this is not Wesley so style he
wants things to be safe for his King
rather than playing this double-edged
game yeah so he definitely took the
safety first approach there and we're
expecting to continue doing that but
it's not necessarily obvious what white
should be doing now uh one move for
example would be just solidifying this
Pawn chain just keeping everything nice
and controlled next move bringing the
bishop out but it's nothing to worry
about for Arjun it's nothing to be
scared of it it just feels like a very
balanced position and I do love the
flexibility of Black's Bishop for
example about to appear on the long
diagonal Black's Queen can choose to go
on either side of the board maybe
towards that white king later on
it's a yeah balanced position early days
these kind of middle games are so much
to do with Bond structures and that's
where really the whole focus is on and
it's mostly on the queen side there are
two weaknesses for each of these players
for white it's that pawn on A5 which
might look like an aggressive Bond but
actually it can often come under
pressure the other one of course the one
right below the A6 Pawn which was Under
Fire and we see both players uh know
that well Archer kind of got out of the
opening neutralizing White's Edge and
looks pretty calm so far
Wesley there shifting a little bit David
what's your chest pose
what would you what would be your chest
pose uh my chest post sir Tanya oh I
don't know just
not really it's more like these two just
uh heading hands hiding from the world I
feel like we can pull up that chest pose
you know if the producers back there a
certain photo that's been happening uh
with a gold medal around his neck and a
shirt off his body so I feel like that's
your ultimate chest pose that's true
yeah you caught me out on that one I
wonder if it's allowed to turn up like
uh like that to a chessboard
well there was a lot of talk about dress
code in the rapid and Blitz World
Championship right uh Magnus was it that
showed up and
not I guess they call it appropriate
clothing because it wasn't like
shirt or suit what was the problem there
I think he was wearing a puma hoodie
there and it was the day that he showed
up really late for his game and game
running I think it was a Blitz game
you've got three minutes on the on the
clock the guy just runs in with 30
seconds left two and a half minutes late
uh and uh yeah Freda does have a very
strict dress code for their official
championships they do tend to give out
warnings first before they take Serious
action but then yeah just seeing Magnus
run with his hoodie on and then go on to
win in just 30 seconds that was insane
so tell me he's running he's wearing
Puma gear and he's winning again with
minimal time so that sounds like a
hashtag ad and maybe that's why he got
the warning you know they kind of hit
you on the wrist for that one I bet Puma
was very happy I also remember from
Fisher random World Championship
got told off also for no uh dressing
appropriately I think is what they said
that's such Rebels
they're all doing it for the memes
that's for sure yeah and that's uh
what's so nice about online chess as
well they can basically wear whatever
they want so the question from David is
can they be shirtless
I don't want fide writing into me you
know giving me a warning already I'm not
actually going to do it but how cool
would it be okay so let's say you're
wearing your shirt but you turn up to
your next over the board event just
wearing your gold medals
[Laughter]
uh anyway
Wesley says in the tank he's been
thinking for around three four minutes
now
uh a long time and Tanya I wanted to ask
you actually the previous days but now
feels like the perfect moment Arjun arag
I see this massive sponsorship deal uh
record-breaking I believe oh how much do
you think it's going to help him a lot I
think this is exactly what's required to
step it up and go to the next level of
course all these youngsters their
ultimate dream is to fight for the world
championship match and we've seen with
Arjun he's had such a breakout
performance over the last two years a
meteoric rise really just came out with
a boom out of the pandemic and you know
Crossing 2700 being one of the top rapid
players in the world just some
star-started tournaments he played and
really marked his own over there
established himself with the elite and
then it is about being super strong to
really taking up taking it up that Notch
and for that you need that financial
support and I think that money is going
to be put into some good use some good
training I know they've mixed it up with
the trainers and sort of um arjuns
getting help from some of the best in
the world now with that so it's going to
go a long way in his dream of becoming a
world champion one day yeah I believe it
was around 1.5 dollars that's incredible
and it was a single Singaporean company
I'm half Singaporean you know where's
the money
it's an action yeah it's with Arjun and
he deserves it he's uh he's been so
great and do you think this could be the
start of a new trend for younger players
uh you know each having their individual
sponsors
I actually think the champion Chester
has played a huge role in that I mean we
saw the entire explosion happen with
that Prague big win I think it was in
the air things Masters yeah it was the
first time in 2022 February it was yeah
yeah it's basically one year ago exactly
a year ago and chess exploded in India
we had our prime minister tweeting about
it we had such a tender good tweeting
about it and that's when it got into
this big mainstream news and of course
with that performances backed by that
because that's really where it's at uh
people have been taking notice of these
young talents and the support has been
coming in and I think that's what's
required in our spot to make that next
jump for this new wave this wave of
these teenagers yeah to really shake up
the elite in the world absolutely that
you can actually make a living of Chess
from an early age
absolutely and I think this money the
sponsorship money it just goes into your
training and to step up to that very
next level because this jump from 2700
to fighting for the world championship
is is way bigger than it seems and I
think it's the hardest one to make yeah
yeah it gets incrementally harder right
the higher you go up the rating ladder
the harder it is to make those uh those
gains and uh we've seen plenty of people
try to challenge Magnus but not quite
kind of stay at that 2800 level
consistently like you can and even in
India we've had vishianen but we haven't
had another Vision since him uh so much
darling so many youngsters and I think
this is the generation that's going to
change that yeah we know chess is
booming in India what would you say is
the state of Chess in the U.S Robert
it's kind of a complicated question
because the U.S has been criticized in
recent years for bringing in Talent from
around the globe levonne Ronin is now
playing for the U.S Federation in recent
years Wesley so is one of the players
and of course we welcome them with open
arms uh but at the younger levels it's
kind of the Grassroots levels chess is
booming in the U.S and many more people
are playing the game I think people too
often focus on the top players don't see
everyone that's working up the youngest
Grandmaster in chess history from the
United States Christopher you who uh
like gukesh has composed puzzles and is
a strong Grandmaster in his teenage
years from the United States so we are
seeing many strong talents including Sam
Sevin who is in the third division uh
Grand Final right now so there is a lot
going for the U.S but I think people
like to compare to the top of the world
and Fabiano caruana Hikaru Nakamura like
where's that next player coming from
it's really really difficult to get
there yeah
must be a name that you know could be a
potential next world champion at some
point when the youngest Grand Master in
chess history I think there's a lot of
pressure on you and of course there are
others as well like Tani I mean his
story is very famous uh in a book and I
believe it's going to be in into a movie
so there's so many talented players
around the globe and we're just treated
to see them play yeah yeah we had Tony
on the show last year what a cool guy uh
definitely a big chess Talent now in
this one a bunch of moves on the board
what's happening yeah a bunch of Trades
we did see a couple of minor pieces
leave the board the pawn structure is
almost the same as it was when we last
talked about the game but uh black has
fixed things in the center lock things
down and uh it's this bishop versus
night scenario and of course we're
talking in previous days about it being
a matter of style being a matter of
taste but with this porn structure it
definitely feels like the night holds
its own against the bishop white does
have the opportunity to try and trade
off later on capture that black knight
but that doesn't lead to any advantage
with the extra Central pawns for black
with the extra central control it
definitely feels like the more pieces
come off the board the happier Argent
will be right now and big decision I
don't think you should rush to trade
Queens we should mention here Robert but
uh what else could Archer be thinking
about I just think it was a brilliant
last move from Wesley so because so many
people would say I can't allow you to
take my queen and double isolate my
pawns but if black does grab the queen
right now it'd be a huge mistake because
Pawn structure down in there ditski
let's say it's overrated people look at
the Aesthetics after the capture The
Rook is forced back and then white can
in fact take this Knight on C5 once The
Rook Retreats because the open D file is
so important in particular the D5 square
that Rook hits two pawns at the same
time there's no way for black to defend
them White's just gonna go upon grabbing
it's going to be happy picking for
Wesley so there's no way our generic I
see is trading Queens despite how bad
the white Pawn structure would look yep
it would look terrible but you win a
pawn in the process uh at the very
minimum uh so Arjun here he was he will
for sure be looking in a different
direction does he just maintain the
status quo
um I guess you can move this Rook I'm
not sure where you want to place it this
night at some point you can just Retreat
it back to a safe Square this Rook is a
bit stuck I love this piece just a few
moves ago but suddenly now it's tied
down as a defensive piece holding and
protecting its own night it's never
really going to be able to gobble up
this Pawn which is well defended by
white truck so this Rook does look like
a clumsy piece normally Rooks you want
them shifting across the board on open
lines here it's just very locked in so I
don't like that piece at all for Arjun
but the rest of his position very solid
I don't see any specific threats for
white uh if black just takes the time
out just as an example pushes a pawn I
don't see what Wesley's doing next maybe
it is this idea that Robert mentioned of
lifting The Rook but that also looks
clumsy its own right there would be some
tactics there potentially and both sides
having loose pieces so I do expect Arjun
to play the waiting game just a very
slow move here but it's not necessarily
his style it's not what he likes to do
he's going to be trying to calculate and
solve problems that way but arjun's
style is to be more aggressive but if he
tries to do that in this position by
going after that week a pawn with the
Knight falling back to B7 yes it looks
as if that a pawn is undefendable and
you're going to end up losing it but
actually this would be a huge mistake
because now the White Queen gets so
active David you go Queen to C6 and
you're hitting that A6 spawn and this is
a trade that is going to result in
White's favor because take a look at
this if you capture the air Pawn with
the Knight
Queen takes A6 hits The Rook hits the
Knight and you actually end up losing a
lot of material so right now you need to
play it a little slowly like you're
saying makeup on move make a rook move
and I like this because now what he's
done is he's defended that A6 spawn he's
threatening to go back with the Knight
to B7 the idea that I was just
discussing and if the queen moves
forward then at least the A6 Pawn is
defended yeah that's what we call
prophylaxis in chests such as defending
against threats that haven't yet
appeared on the board and uh he's just
covering his weak pawns covering any
potential threats for white so really
nice classy move there from Arjun it did
cost him a bit of time and now the
players are roughly balanced on the
clock
the Queens are eyeing up each other what
what is your tip for
for you know uh beginners in chess uh in
a position like this do you want to keep
the Queens on the board you want to get
rid of them what is the best tip it's
always going to be situation dependent
but in terms of this position in
particular uh the queen trade if white
captures black queen it welcomes the
black king towards the center in the end
game that's very important and from
Black's point of view you want to take
the queen to ruin White's Pawn structure
but we were talking about those lines
where the white Rook gets too active
after a series of Trades so you
typically would say to keep the tension
until you're entirely ready to release
it and this is a great example that
neither side really wants to budge and I
think we're going to see Wesley play a
move with a pawn over on the king side
likely his F2 Pawn up to F3 just to
create a pawn chain and defend his pawns
the tension is going to remain here it's
not always easy to give a kind of a
blueprint of what to do when Queens are
staring at each other yeah I have a very
young student and uh okay there we go
Robert predicting the move correctly and
uh this young student her instinct is to
trade pieces anytime There's an
opportunity she'll make the trade she
doesn't even think just because she
assumes that the end game will be
simpler easier to understand but the
thing is you have to trade on your own
terms you have to make sure you don't
give your opponent two or three Tempo uh
Tempe there for example if white does go
and trade off and allow the black king
into the center that only improves the
black position if black trades off you
improve the white position so you have
to make sure it's on your own terms you
don't rush and you don't worsen your
position in the meantime and there we go
Tanya you uh yeah you have your profit
hat on again predicting this night
Retreat you know I liked it at first but
uh while you were just talking about
this great advice about trading on your
terms I got a little worried about it
because
yes you're hitting A5 and once white
moves the queen to C6 the A6 spawn would
be attacked but I thought the Rook was
hanging but instead Wesley chooses a
different approach here he actually
moved the Rook up to D5 to defend that
A5 pawn and look at this archon not even
taking a moment immediately blitzes out
the move C5 and what he's done is he's
made his intentions clear he wants to
pick up that A5 Pawn but in the bargain
he's made this D6 Pawn such a huge
weakness same with confidence confidence
confidence also very committal and this
is the type of move that I would never
dream of it wouldn't be on my radar I've
got to say I just from the way I was
taught when I was young don't make
long-term weaknesses in your position uh
black certainly has weakened the pawn
structure Roberts talks about the base
of the structure before and Black's
night is tied down forever now Wesley's
Queen has got out of Dodge and yes you
can take that white a pawn that corner
Pawn at any time you want but you might
lose the whole of your Pawn Center in
the process uh yeah very instrumental
decision it's the type of move that has
become more accessible to humans with
the Advent of the engines if you show
this position to a Grandmaster from 1950
they would say what is wrong with you
that C5 move was terrible out of the
question because it completely ruins
your Pawn structure and yet we see the
Eva bar it's sliding slightly in White's
favor but it's because it's hard for
white to do anything The Rook on A1 in
the corner tied down to the defense of
the A5 Pawn The Rook on B5 for black is
staring right at it and the D6 Pawn it's
hard to pile up more pressure on it and
the Knight is a good defender of that
pawn especially when the Rook is leading
the way so I feel like that type of move
has become increasingly common in modern
times but if you went back to that
famous book Zurich 1953 and we're
analyzing with the legends of the day
and show them that move C5 they would
say get out of here this you're not a
strong player our generic icy is strong
he is well aware that he can hold down
the fort despite appearances yeah I do
worry however if the Knight is stuck on
this Square as a defensive piece
therefore The Rook is stuck on this
Square it can never Retreat and this
rook in the Corner may be stuck
defending this uh this loose Pawn then
suddenly Wesley might switch his Focus
switch his attention swing his Rook over
even if it comes at the cost of this
weak a pawn and uh when he does leave
her open the position open things up
then things might turn against the black
king uh suddenly the Black Knight is
caught on the wrong side of the board it
can never act as a Defender Archer does
switch his Rook across and uh what do
you guys think and I will go for that
now this was important because if we can
just show this point that Robert was
making that if actually black did pick
up the A5 Pawn giving up the D6 pawn it
just shows what a disaster black spawn
structure would have been you know
you've still got a weakness on Asics the
C5 Pawn is super weak and it just feels
as a Black's position is going to fall
apart which is why Arjun decided to now
reshuffle the position a bit put that
rook in the center it seems to move C5
was made to just make the position once
again get it into a little more Dynamic
territory but very committal there
creates this long-term lifelong weakness
of D6 and I have a bad feeling that this
might come to haunt our journey yeah he
still needs a few moves to arrange the
POS
sible Wesley has this luxury now he has
two or three moves to try and build up
whether that's playing on the other side
of the board trying to push this Pawn
forward or not whether he finds a
different plan uh that's what Wesley's
going to be thinking about for only four
minutes against six he needs to speed up
so was he you know he can do what Dave
was suggesting slide The Rook over to
the king side but that creates a dynamic
position and that's when the clock
becomes a real factor a Wesley for now
he can kind of sit on the position it's
locked up he can make small moves but
with only four minutes and counting down
on his clock he does not want to enter
tactical territory against origin
eriggaisi who is an absolute wizard when
pieces are flying
and I think this is where we can see The
Clash of Styles as we've been talking
about if Arjun was playing with the
white pieces David I could have bet that
your idea would have been on the board
with the Rook sliding down to the f file
say give up that pawn on A5 you know I'm
playing for the initiative and if all of
Black's pieces are on the king side we
would have seen that Rook F1 F4 break
that you were hinting at but of course
Wesley keeping everything under control
just going for a more solid approach
keeps the tension as is makes a small
little move H3 and Arjun wanting to keep
the pressure on the clock also makes an
equally useful move when in doubt just
create a little space for your king yeah
and it definitely feels like Wesley is
just maintaining the status quo not
feeling that he can go for it yet with
just three minutes on the clock not
making any uh Dynamic decisions we've
had this uh debate in the past I know a
lot of top chess players they look at
Wesley they see one of the most talented
players out there his instincts just
supreme but uh he doesn't like taking
these risks it's as if he hates losing
more than he enjoys winning and uh it
just feels to me these last supplements
yes he's potentially preparing a pawn
break with F4 but he's not really sure
what to do he doesn't really want to
choose a specific plan and go for it and
the A5 Pawn is a long-term weakness so
if black can slide his Rook up from EA
to E6 defend that pawn on D6 maybe bring
the queen on over to the other side of
the board the A5 Pawn may be falling and
that's what Wesley has to look out for
black doesn't have the time to just put
all the pieces over on the queen side
because that moved F3 to F4 for white
uses a battery ramp open that flank
that's what Wesley needs to consider and
his last move hints at that he brought
his Queen back a square so F4 becomes a
viable option and with that Rook on A1
eventually sliding towards the king side
we could see him take this into tactical
Waters and queen F6 from origin it
prevents that move F4 if we just show
that quickly that would be a huge
blunder because after politics Pawn The
Rook on A1 is in fact loose so it's a
multi-purpose move it defends the pawn
on D6 another time it also prevents that
F4 move which is kind of White's only
big idea I like the way that both
players are handling this they're
keeping the tension the status quo but I
like arjun's clock a bit more because he
has the extra time yeah and both sides
just playing with their kings there it's
definitely a waiting game just both
sides kind of playing copycat moving a
pawn putting the king behind that pawn
it's a waiting game neither side willing
to make that first move to break the
tension and I think we'll have to wait
for a few more maneuvering moves before
finally once I cracks and just lashes
out and either sacrifices a pawn if
you're Wesley so or uh yeah goes for
that pawn if you're Argent erig I see I
like your colorful analysis board now
David yeah I didn't even mean to do the
colors it just it just happened they're
very nice very pretty and we also think
it's very nice when you guys share your
selfies so today this is the air things
monsters every day we are giving out an
air things device signed by Magnus
Carlsen himself and we're going to give
out one device today to uh someone who
shares a cool selfie using chess Champs
on Twitter so go ahead and share your
selfies how are you watching the show
who are you watching with where are you
watching it
we want to know so send your selfie and
preferably in landscape mode and was
that a little bit of a draw offered by
Wesley just shuffling his Queen one step
ahead and then bringing it back in Arjun
saying no I want to play on oh
potentially and uh Arjun of course he's
not known for his tendency to make draws
he's known for being very ambitious he's
a fighter David yeah he'll fight on
surely yeah absolutely he's going to
play this till the end and that's just
his style of play regardless of who he's
playing against and look at those last
couple of moves Robert that Wesley's
gone for the queen went to D2 then a
step back and then it's now back again
to D3 and that just makes one feel that
Wesley perhaps doesn't really know what
he wants to do right now and maybe he's
claiming that black can make no progress
either and there is kind of a hidden
threat the queen is eyeing The Rook on
B5 so if you are not looking out for it
if you make a careless move the queen
when the pawn still existed could have
sacrificed so if we just take a move
back and the Knight didn't take the pawn
uh let's say instead of grabbing the
pawn A5 yeah that move H5 Queen takes B5
is something that you have to consider
because the pawn takes A6 Knights are
very clumsy if the Knight moves back to
save itself then the pawn goes up to A7
it's Unstoppable going to the other side
of the board so I think Wesley was
trying just to move back and forth and
say you are not just going to have a
free hand and now we see that Arjun
takes the pawn A5 but he's Frozen in
place if the Knight moves away now the
A6 Pawn Falls uh if the Knight just
stays on the rim that's looking a bit
dim and that D6 Pawn remains a Target I
think that we're at a bit of a
standstill and white is no worse yeah
he's happily giving out that pawn but
now Arjun is the one with the more
difficult questions to answer and if you
can't bring this Knight into play it's
very very awkward we might see another
repetition of the position if black just
kind of sidesteps yoyos with the queen
why just sidesteps and yoyos with his
Queen and neither side making progress I
do wonder whether Wesley will be
thinking of sliding the Queen the whole
way across to the corner just to put
extra pressure on that night force it to
move by Brute Force but uh yeah we will
see first of all how Arjun is feeling
about his chances he does sidestep with
his Queen at least he can slide back to
defend this night give it Extra
Protection if he really needs to later
on but uh still very tense as Robert
says I don't believe white is worth here
despite that pawn deficit temporarily
I'm very impressed with arjun's decision
to not repeat moves even once I don't
know if Wesley intended to actually
continue with the repetition and we'll
perhaps never know that but Arjun makes
his intentions really clear that he
wants to take his chances and this is
what we've been discussing right that
Archer needs to stick to his style he
needs to create Chaos on the board uh
has to have that ice water in my Wayne's
approach here
so I I mean against a player like Wesley
with the black pieces most of us well
I'm not even going to put myself in that
category but like most players would be
happy to take a repetition and say you
know what I get white in the next round
you want to repeat I'm happy but Arjun
here fighting this out is that what they
teach in the Indian School of chastanya
I never see you take quick draws either
I always see you [__] up to the very
end
I have you know I've always thought that
female chess players they have a thing
for fighting it out till the end I don't
think we're very comfortable taking
draws I think we're Fighters like that
ah yeah and I see Robert looking at me
with his eyebrows raised no nothing is
what you were saying look at the last
movie that was played lastly so also is
not in the business of making a drawn
repeating moves he pushes his Pawn to F4
and he's saying let's go if he can get
one more move a free turn he would push
that pawn forward and create an attack
with his pawns against the black king So
if black says I don't want any part of
that let me take your Pawn on F4 well
thank you very much my Bishop is finally
free those black pawns on the dark
squares we're making sure that Bishop
had nowhere to go now D6 is hanging
three white pieces attacking it at The
Rook on B5 stuck defending the Knight
over there if the Knight moves back to
B7 to defend the pawn D6 down goes your
A6 pawn and your Rook on B5 is loose and
kind of trapped as well so D6 is a
problem point for our generic guy scene
I think he's going to regret taking that
pawn A5 sometimes your biggest strength
is your biggest weakness in playing
Fighting Chess can backfire and I think
we are seeing the signs of that right
now and look at the clock as well Arjun
now
has got less time than Wesley so with
all these trades that have happened the
D6 Pawn is a weakness uh but yeah I was
just uh you know just to finish that
point I think very rarely will you find
um quick draws in uh in women chest stop
events as long as the music Chuck
sisters are not playing
I'm not trying to call them being honest
family over everything Robert actually
it's calculation over everything you're
gonna talk to James candy a little bit
and uh meanwhile okay look at the
evaluation bar because that black D6
Pawn has dropped yes it's come at the
cost of white Central Pawn but uh if you
count the pieces in the center in the
center of the board white is up those
two black pieces the black Rook the
Black Knight on the edge they're
balanced out by whites Rook black is
essentially playing a whole night down
and if the attention does switch towards
the king side towards the Kings it's
black who will be suffering so again the
count here doesn't matter stop the count
that black extra Pawn irrelevant and I
really fear for arjun's life here this
turned around really quickly and he's
coming down on the clock as well but
it's it's kind of level here right now
but huge threats with that Rook landing
on with a check on d8 which will force
the king up to a square where it might
pin the rookani for uh so big threats
the one thing that is going for Arjun
here is that Wesley's Rook on A4 is a
little stuck imagine if that could come
all the way down and join the attack
from the f-file or the e-file that would
be an absolute disaster but this is
looking tricky Arjun needs to keep
control over his nerves and make All the
Right Moves to defend this one yeah
massive threat on the board as Tanya
said that if black just plays kind of an
irrelevant move then there will be a
nasty check and there's nowhere good for
this King to go just to highlight your
point here maybe the safest Square would
be walking into a pin and you don't want
to see that one appear if you're black
so uh huge threat how does he neutralize
that one you could maybe swap off a set
of Rooks at the cost of a pawn but uh
that's a hard move to make because then
you'll always be fighting for only a
draw and it's not Arjun style but maybe
damage limitation is the name of the
game and okay he does choose that move
just to trade off one of White's active
pieces and after a rook trade yes white
takes the pawn back it's level material
now but black still has a bad Knight
against a very strong Bishop but the
fact that Wesley is thinking here
because he would lose his or and that is
what I was about to say he was thinking
he does not take the Rook immediately he
says I'm gonna trade on my own terms if
you take this Rook if black captured the
queen goes up with check and wins the
Knight on A5 the geometry of this
position is beautiful in White's favor
so what has Wesley accomplished he's
dragged arjun's King out into the Open
The Rook trade has in fact occurred but
the difference is the black king on F7
which means it could be a queen A7 check
over there there are some issues that
black needs to solve and it's even
material but is not a level game and
eight seconds on the clock for Arjun in
a very difficult position where you need
to make very precise defensive moves
seconds left he does retreat his Knight
but the checks don't stop the pressure
doesn't stop check off the check at the
moment and Arjun always really lagging
behind on the clock and he does beg for
a queen trade if Wesley wants a really
safe uh end game now he just trades the
queens and goes for an extra Pawn
White's Rook is ready to grab a pawn but
of course Black's King is weak so you
should keep the Queens on the board and
uh okay we'll follow that advice what do
you think Tanya I I think arjun's now
hoping that Wesley repeats with the
check but I will be shocked if Wesley
gives uh Queen F4 check again and offers
a repetition I don't believe that's
gonna happen David Wes comes to the West
Wesley takes the Queen's offering tries
to go for an end game but uh yeah I
think he'll keep the Queens on as you
said Tanya maybe the key idea at some
point will be to retreat the white Rook
swing it across uh you need to get it to
a better what is happening he's not
going to be a repetition I think
Wesley's gonna bring his Queen on the
diagonal up to C7 with check and freeze
some of Black's pieces when your king is
safer in a position like you want to
keep the Queens on the board so I think
what Wesley is doing is he repeats but
he why would he make a drawer he could
trade Queens go up at Pawn in the end
game so there's no way Wesley so is
thinking let's just make a drawing you
see stock for suggesting Queen C7 check
just bringing the queen to a new square
with check the A6 Pawn is tender if the
Knight drops back oh my gosh he traded
Queens I mean he went for the safe
approach and that's been one of the
biggest problems for Wesley so in his
career so he just takes the safer
approach when he needs to take a little
bit of risk keeping the Queens on the
board Martian gets another life now I
mean he's still down upon and it's a
difficult uh end game to hold but at
least you're not getting checkmated and
Black's Rook is more active than white
stroke whitestruck stuck to the defense
of that weak backwards C Pawn this looks
like there is hope and life still alive
a life still there for Arjun oh but the
clock is ticking foreign taking very
quickly and we did see stockfish gave
white a killer Advantage plus five if
he'd kept the Queens on but uh as you've
both mentioned there suddenly arjun's
going to be breathing a sigh of relief
and uh he's getting his pieces active
that Black Brook very strongly placed
now the knights jumping into the game as
well you're hitting that Bishop on D2
things are getting uh not that easy for
Wesley to convert this one yeah and he's
going to grab a second point he's
currently two pawns up but both the
blacks pieces are on really menacing
squares really active and Robert I think
he might save their Sergeant yeah unless
he is one of the best bullet chess
players in the world so with limited
time on the clock he still can Thrive he
needs to use his outside pass Pawn the H
Pawn and distract Black's forces but are
virgin looking like he is ready to save
this game those pawns on the queen side
C2 and B3 light squares you have a dark
Square Bishop you can't defend them easy
and that's why we see the liquidation uh
Wesley so up a palm but origin Eric is
he understands his next move will Target
that pawn on B3 and that's why Bishop E5
what a smart move and maybe Wesley could
still win this yeah still chances for
sure but there is reduced material so
arjun's best bet if he can remove that
pawn on B3 uh will be to try and get rid
of all of White's pawns even at the cost
of his own night but the Knight isn't on
a great circuit we've got to say at the
moment he's keeping the white king out
the white king cannot advance but at
some point it might start heading
towards that Lone Ranger that black B
Pawn I still think this is great winning
chances for white uh despite only having
a few points left and we see the eval
bar agrees with you David and that's
because Black's Knight cannot get to
that beep on if we can just take away
all the queen side pawns then this will
end in a draw but now what has happened
is that white actually goes on to pick
up the B4 on what Arjun wants to do is
then fall back with the Knight to C1
there will be no way to defend the B3
Pawn the pawns have been traded off and
I would feel that this is a job but the
problem with the Knight is getting
trapped yeah you know you're not coming
back from this Square you're not finding
an any safe squares later on maybe
there's no way to go for the Black
Knight yet as soon as the white king
starts marching towards it the black
king comes down to gobble up the
remaining white Pawn so first Wesley is
fixing that porn situation on the king
side he's going to hope that the black
king can't make any uh Headway towards
them but okay now you can start trying
to pick up that Knight surely there's a
way and
yeah and I was just looking at the clock
okay they're still playing on seconds
and they need to be precise Wesley
they're repeating just one so that he
can get some time on the clock
how is he gonna win that black knight
he's repeated the position twice now he
has to be really careful to avoid the
draw he needs to raise King up there it
is because the Knight goes down the
bishop slice back with check winning the
Knight on C1 so I think Wesley has found
it the Knight is nowhere to go and
that's why the pawn is pushed oh my gosh
those last pawns get traded even up a
bishop it would still be a draw it's
Wesley winning now he should be we've
got to trust the evaluation bar here
because it's pure calculation the margin
for error uh I'm not sure it's very high
that's the only thing we could see the
evaluation bar drop if he makes one slip
but he should be winning and uh luckily
the White H Pawn is the color it does
promote on the h8 Square a dark Square
so it's the same color as the bishop
okay he didn't trap the Knight he didn't
manage to win it but he's two points out
now and the Knight is so far away she
should be winning what do we think and
this is the point if the pawn was the
wrong color David black could have
sacrificed that night for the F4 pawn
and just get his King to the right
square and it would have ended in a draw
but now Arjun has to fight for this one
it is a winning position for Wesley he
still has to show a little bit of
technique but I believe that Wesley will
do this he will take this point home
yeah the problem is it's always going to
be zuk Swang there's no Fortress here
because the Black Knight has to guard
against two pawns and knights can never
lose time they're the worst piece at
losing time white will just wait with
the Bishop from time to time there we go
just improving the bishop and eventually
slowly but surely the white pawns will
start to advance even further because
sometimes Black's best move is no move
at all you can't do that when you have a
knight Bishops okay if they want to go
up two scores they can stop one square
in between where the Knight has to
change his color complex and we see
Wesley bringing his King over to help
the H Pawn run forward the king will
slide over to G4 the H will go up to H5
and the black king and Knight cannot
stop both pawns at the same time and
that right corner is so important
otherwise black could have just
sacrificed the knife for the pawn that
HS it's grabbing the same color as the
bishop that Wesley has just changes the
result of this game it's working after
Wesley he's improved his position the
Knight as you're mentioning don't have
good waiting moves and at the end we can
see Wesley slowly but surely making
progress with his pawns and his King
yeah two are better than none and those
two white pawns both promote on dark
squares which is a bit of a bonus but
look at this Black Knight it's a sad
situation here he's got to retreat it
all the way back home nice and f8
there's no mate I say but not an f8 here
he's not going to help you save the game
and that are advancing eventually you
will your defensive formation will be
broken
getting close to 100 moves in this game
yep we're getting very very close but
these players they aren't paid by the
move unfortunately and uh that won't
save Argent at all uh he's just gonna
wait now he's just gonna move his Knight
back and forth back and forth but
eventually I think there will be ways to
kind of trap that night stalemate that
black knight almost and uh okay first
Wesley's relocating his King bringing
his King the whole whole way round and
uh Black's yeah black blockade isn't
gonna there we go a stalemate of that
black knight the Black Knight has no
moves now without being captured the
black king is gonna have to make way but
uh Wesley will lose a move and he'll
find a way eventually to bring his own
King forward there we go look Swang no
good moves for black if you could pass
it would be a draw but that's not
possible interest you move the king
anywhere the king steps forward you take
away all the squares the Knight will
have to move somewhere now and it either
gets picked up for free or traded
excellent and gameplay by Wesley this
one yeah and uh last still mate trick it
looks like for marching but it doesn't
work you can take that night either way
with your king or your Bishop it's not
not stalemate and I think we have a
result Wesley so has won the game
yep uh has he given up yet our generic I
see yeah he's thrown in the towel yep
Wesley so strikes first chair in the
loser is uh semi-final he is putting our
generic icy in a must-win situation in
game two starting in five minutes
showing no emotion here Wesley silver
watch a game he played and here is
today's Lisa vetta learning point
thank you
so today's learning point is about
trading pieces on your own terms and one
position one scenario not to trade
pieces is when you have the safer King
here there's a standoff between the two
queens white does have the option of
taking the Queens off the board and
Wesley so against Arjun Eric I see he
did go for this but he almost spoiled
his winning chances he took the win in
the end but with a bit of luck he should
have kept the Queens on the board this
queen check would have been devastating
forcing the Black Knight back and now
white could actually win in a variety of
ways you can go after this Pawn in the
next few moves for white it's extremely
weak you can try and get this Rook back
in the game you can bring your Bishop in
to try and Target this pinned Black
Knight it would have been all over
within a few moves instead Wesley so
traded off and this black king breathes
a sigh of relief it was no longer in
trouble and after recapturing we saw
that suddenly black was on the attack
White had to go passive and black had
great drawing chances so only trade
pieces if it really helps your position
all right we are learning and take a
quick twitch break right now for anyone
who is not a subscriber for everyone
else well we're gonna announce the
puzzle of today
[Music]
ah Ivanka is coming into the studio
we've just seen Wesley wind putting
Arjun in a must win situation in game
two that's gonna be a dramatic game that
is certainly going to be dramatic and I
have to say a very impressive stuff from
Wesley and I have to say it looked like
he'd been reading the Sun Tzu's Art of
War you know appear week when you are
strong
right I mean I liked that one very good
and talking about great end game
technique he wasn't the only one Fabiana
caruana just defeated uh you yangy with
the black pieces in an excellent Bishop
end game in division two division two
they are playing the winners they are
playing the winners and when it came to
the Grand Final in division three it was
the craziest game I've ever seen in my
life between pregnant and Sam Savion
I've never seen a king get out there in
the middle game so openly but uh it
didn't work out for Sam Sabian so it was
a draw it was it no it was a loss it was
a loss it was a loss So Pregnant takes
the lead with the black pieces
takes the lead in The Grand Final in
division three this is the best of two
games in the Grand Final in division
three two young players fighting it out
there and
um I started Ivanka we're gonna announce
the puzzle of today you always bring a
puzzle with you for the viewers on what
you have and today today is no exception
and it's actually a study
um composed by afanas afana seif and
here it is it's white to play as always
and it does look like you know even a
white is a knight and two pawns up well
he's in trouble because that pawn on E2
is gonna promote but how does white save
themselves
ha so the puzzle is white to play why to
play and save yourself save yourself win
I'm gonna leave it up to the viewers to
decide because I think it's a bit of a
giveaway if I tell them yeah okay so uh
here it is get cracking it's a great fun
one as well yeah again another one to
involve the friends the family and uh
once you've figured it out share it on
social media yeah share it with everyone
you know definitely
all right there you have the puzzle
everyone so get cracking at it but uh
you also need to follow game two in the
loser semi-final it's coming up very
shortly some more action between Wesley
so and Arjun all right guys see your
subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
mm-hmm
we're getting ready for game two and the
loser semi-final between Wesley so and
Arjun Eric ICN Tanya you said it it's
actually a huge advantage to start out
with the white pieces like Wesley did
here on the losers bracket where there's
only two games and Arjun he's in a
Muslim situation now he has to win on
demand well at least his task is cut out
for him but the bad news is he's playing
Wesley so yeah and Wesley is one of
those guys once he's taken the lead in a
match he goes Super clinical and he's
happy to just play solid not take any
chances he'll just block everything that
you can create well Arjun does have the
white pieces now so I think it really
comes down to what kind of position
comes right out of the opening if it is
something even Robert David I don't
believe that Arjun then has a chance he
has to make sure right out of the
opening we get something absolutely
crazy it's a basically one of the
hardest things to do in chess today to
beat Wesley soul on demand what's this
there was a brick wall you do not want
to punch against it you're going to
break your hand that said Arjun Eric icy
he's willing to lose and that's the most
important thing when you have to win he
doesn't just play a safe style where
he's going to draw the game he will give
it everything he has a play something
maybe dubious that Wesley doesn't
suspect and he needs to catch Wesley so
off guard because when he's prepared we
saw what he did against Hikaru Nakamura
there was nothing he didn't even bend
let alone break I feel like I want to
put that in quotes and put it on my
Twitter account what was it the most
important thing when you have to win is
to be willing to lose very good all
right yeah
what do you expect from Arjun coming
into this must win game David yeah I
also expect him to come all guns blazing
against Wesley so I'm not sure the
opening because he does play Everything
Under the Sun maybe a London system but
with a knight coming to C3 I'm not sure
what we're allowed to call it these days
for that one but uh yeah something
aggressive something that keeps all the
pieces on the board and asks questions
early he did beat Wesley with the white
pieces in the Blitz in the Tata steel a
rapid in India and there we saw jubava
London so Mike pissing but no he
completely switches it up with one E4
and we've got an Italian I was hoping
from Evan's Gambit but we didn't see
that the Evans Camp is when white
sacrifices the pawn for a quick
initiative I think that's been proven
that it doesn't quite work out and there
is quite a lot of theory that helps you
pair it off so I think we're getting a
solid star thus far I like this though
Bishop G5 just posing some questions in
the early going against Wesley so yeah
the one thing I will say however about
bringing the bishop out to G5 early is
that Arjun has been doing it from time
to time recently he played this in tata
steel he's been playing this in the
world Blitz the world rapid and uh
Wesley if he's done his due diligence
and if he's done some research on this
opening he will have been able to
predict uh what Arjun is up to here I
remember Arjun played maybe the most
bizarre looking novelty I've ever seen
against ding in Vikings just a couple of
weeks ago playing this bizarre Rook move
that no human could ever understand but
a human might recommend and so far very
standard stuff it does look like black
as we can just King Side by pushing upon
forward to G5 but he has broken a nasty
pin and kicked back White's dark Square
Bishop to a bit of a blunted square so
uh still early days but uh well-known
territory standard David and as you were
mentioning Robert you're impressed with
that approach with the bishop going to
G5 and the main idea is to try to
provoke black to make these pawn moves
and of course all of this has been done
before we are still in theory but just
having this kind of position where black
has advanced those King Pawns in front
and weaken a few squares you never know
how this will go and the whole idea is
to make it turbulent so I think that's a
good opening approach there's one
problem it seems like Wesley so knows
how this is going to go because he's
throwing his kingside pawns up with
Reckless abandon he's like let's print
G5 let's go H5 and hold nothing back and
that's the sign of a well-prepared
player uh Arjun tried to strike in the
center with D4 Wesley says I'm gonna go
after your minor piece in the king side
brings this queen out to reinforce the
E5 Pawn so it does seem like Wesley so
knows everything here that's a big
problem for Arjun area guys see I like
the type of position we have but I also
like Wesley so's preparation and Dr
goldton in the twitch chat saying when
is the last time Wesley so even lost a
game never yeah he never loses yeah wow
literally this tournament he's unbeaten
so far uh two title Tuesdays Vikings
they didn't lose the game I don't think
he's lost in 2023 yet yeah what a what a
year it's so amazing and he said one of
his goals for 23 is to win a big online
event and it looks like he wants to make
the most of the second shot that he has
well he did win it last year with a
global championship and Wesley saw
taking the lead in this match and
playing confidently and taking his
chances in the second one as well yeah
the winner of this match will go through
to face Hikaru Nakamura and the losers
final starting right after this match
has finished and the winner of the
losers final will meet Magnus Carlsen in
the grand final tomorrow
will it be Wesley so will it be Arjun
aragaisy or Hikaru Nakamura
and Kaya on your birthday uh what do you
want to see do you want to see Arjun uh
win this one fight back from again or do
you want to see a Wesley sir against
your current Nakamura uh final I I want
to see Armageddon
whoever it is
so is a very nice guy so if he hears
this he probably would say all right
Kyle Armageddon for your birthday sounds
like a nice present and we are getting a
fight that could lead to that Armageddon
but every single turn it feels like
Wesley so is moving instantly that must
strike some fear into our generic guys
see he needs to win this game but the
position is incredibly Dynamic right now
we see the black king side it is open
you've thrown your pawns forward which
means they're weak squares left behind
and white has given up the bishop the
last move captured the Knight on C6 and
then black was able to capture back so
the pawn structure is bad on the left
side of the board the Queen side and the
the rights of the board the king side
because the pawns are sticking out like
sore thumbs that said the bishop on A7
such a strong piece for black staring
all the way across the board to the
enemy King I feel like Wesley you know
he's now slowing down he might finally
be out of preparation yeah and uh just a
few moves ago we saw him pause for 30
seconds he looked off to his left side
and normally when players are staring
off to the left staring off into the air
uh they're activating that side of their
brain which is the memory part where so
he was just recalling his opening notes
but now for the first time he's really
looking into the board trying to work
things out so I think you're right
Robert he's on his own for the first
time in this game and it's not the type
of position you want to be on your own
you want to know exactly what's going on
here because multiple threats white is
eyeing up this Pawn this Pawn is
undefended or not sufficiently defended
right now at this point you could at
least hint at capturing at some point
and how does Wesley deal with both of
those threats you don't want to take out
time out now and just play an ugly
looking move you don't really have the
luxury of lining things up and defending
and of course he plays dynamically more
energetically he attacks the White Queen
instead so once this White Queen moves
it's not clear where she goes but for
example if she steps up there might be a
drawback the Bishops will suddenly allow
line and look at this nasty pin along
this diagonal combine it with this
bishop and this is nasty stuff for white
so I'm more expecting Arjun now to slide
the other way with this queen okay he
has gone out I was going to say maybe
offer a trade of Queens because you do
have the better Pawn structure long term
but Arjun remember he's a much more
ambitious player than me and he does go
after these black weaknesses many many
pawns are for grabs now I'm into it I
really like the way origin is playing
Wesley so is capable of playing
energetic Dynamic style but he's forced
into it in this game he really didn't
have a choice based on arjun's opening
so Arjun picking a great opening and a
must win game and now the dynamic is
very difficult for black to deal with
because C6 is hanging If you defend that
pawn E5 is loose so you have multiple
pawns and look at Wesley so play he
brings his Knight to F6 the reason why
is the bishop on A7 is a very powerful
piece his next move will be a knight
jump over to H5 where it attacks the
bishop which is not defended there is a
pawn connecting to it but that pawn is
pinned and so White's pieces on the king
side those minor pieces not really doing
all that much so giving up material for
the activity and Wesley so knows it's
well worth it this is a stunning move
what a way to defend the position you
just go for the offense and just taking
Robert's point forward uh you know you
can pick up that pawn on E5 the Central
Pawn the keep on in Black's position
with two pieces but both bad idea is
that knife comes Knight H5 and your
Bishop is suddenly trapped you don't
have a good Square for it everything's
hanging the Knight on E5 will be hanging
or you lose the bishop on the other hand
just to point out the power of that
Bishop on A7 if you pick that E5 on up
with the bishop then David you got this
Banger move G3 on the board just
blasting the position open that Bishop
on A7 an absolute monster you can't grab
that G3 pawn bishop takes G3 you say
wait what just happened nothing happened
because there's a pin you simply pick up
the bishop with your queen thank you
very much game over and which is why
Wesley goes uh for this move Knight F6
Arjun responds with a bit of greed but
for the other Pawn takes the pawn on C6
and for now The Rook on A8 is under
attack so you don't have the time to
make the move Knight H5 what I'm
expecting from Wesley is a simple
developing move you can move that Bishop
from C8 and say my Rook is defunded if
you want to pick up the C7 Pawn go ahead
but then once again the Knight can find
its way to H5 but Rook C8 would be even
stronger picking up that night on C4 yep
a bunch of tactics here in the air and
uh once Wesley does defend uh his Rook
or develop his Bishop then the threats
will be maintained they will continue
and uh Arjun has to make sure they don't
spiral out of control I'm looking at the
clock times Arjun does have 14 minutes
so it feels like he's still in or around
his opening preparation it's something
he's cooked up at home but uh yeah it
certainly is the type of position that
could go anyway in either direction and
for Wesley that's not 100 comfortable
when he only needs a draw and look at
his chest pose now yeah that is full of
focus we haven't seen that one from
Wesley yet yeah that's like Batman type
of focus it's like making a mask with
his own hands
in there yeah not letting anything from
the outside world distract him Wesley so
big decision to be made still a decent
position according to the eval bar so uh
we've got to assume that his Pawn
sacrifice was justified objectively
correct but so hard to handle for humans
this one it's not the same exact
position that happened the Olympia but
I'm just recalling a game between no
dierberg Abdul sataurav and patalahari
Krishna because in the Olympia Heart
Christian beat him with black and was
able to win a really nice game and
important game for the Indian team so it
has that same Contours where black goes
for the attack the king looks a bit
exposed Black's pawns look overextended
but really it's White's king that's in
danger but I do like this I keep saying
it that Arjun air guys see he doesn't
mind losing he may lose this game but he
is begging Wesley so to answer important
questions do you have enough
compensation that vague term for
sacrifice material you're down one Pawn
right now and that night on C4 which is
attacking multiple pawns it can always
swing back to block that Bishop on A7
the other night from H2 can go back next
to the King on F1 and you can just put
your pieces together make sure that you
have a compact structure and then you
say to Wesley you sure you're good you
are down upon it might become two but
Arjun right now is a man who has nothing
to lose a jaw or a
us will mean the same thing so only one
result works out for him which also
helps him make these Brave decisions uh
once he's taken this step of moving the
queen in One Direction he has to pick up
those pawns and ask Wesley the question
show me what you got show me where your
money is and Wesley with this Pawn
structure having already lost the pawn
needs to continue with the momentum with
the pressure on with the initiative and
not care about material anymore it is
all about the attack that he can build
against White's King against that Bishop
on G3 West is slowing down a little bit
and look at that clock look at that
clock Wesley's got eight minutes arjun's
taken a minute up till now and he was
shaking his head slightly Wesley so
you're not happy at all out of his
comfort zone he wanted a stable Pawn
structure where he could just slowly
maneuver slowly find his way into the
game the one thing I will say from
personal experience is uh you don't want
to poke the bear if you poke Wesley
he'll he'll come at you he'll find a way
because he's so Universal when he needs
to be when he wants to be but right now
he's not enjoying it too much I'm
expecting him to go for a move that's uh
Natalia just move the light Square
Bishop I'm not sure where you move it
for black but just connect your Rooks
and go from there the threats will
continue but we do hope uh you guys at
home are enjoying the air things
monsters and enjoying the show that what
they saw in Arjun era Garcia is putting
on right now I know some people uh are
enjoying a watch party together right
now at the good night look at that
air things uh people at the good night
having a watch party enjoying the chess
that is very cool maybe we should go to
the good night later today you guys oh
it's so fun it's my favorite place here
I mean if anyone's in Oslo find yourself
here any time of the year you've got to
go to the good night it is the coolest
chess Pub that I've ever seen yeah I'll
race you there
I want to know the air quality there as
well yeah but you have the you know
Advantage because you're local you know
how to get there Tanya's relying on you
you have a bunch of good memories from
the good night now you did really well
in the pub quiz together with Magnus
Carlsen you guys teamed up and you won
the chess game together with Tanya
against David and iwaka
happy birthday
at the good night when we go there this
chess club in Oslo
and uh meanwhile Robert a profit again
dropping the night back now uh Arjun
very safe Square I just love it uh
keeping things compact as you described
and keeping things nice and safe look at
the clock right now Wesley so is down to
about 6 minutes 20 seconds and origin
has barely spent any time so I think for
Wesley one of the pivotal questions that
he's asking himself is how much deeper
is origin's preparation we saw Arjun
impress Vichy Anand at the Tata steel
event in India where he was saying oh I
have this 10 more moves and it was
already moved 30. so this is scary for a
player it may objectively be okay for
black but you make one mistake and that
evil bar jumps up and says that white
has a huge Edge so I think right now for
Wesley he needs to bring his Knight over
to the rim we keep talking about these
ideas the Knight attacking the bishop he
needs to go forward he doesn't have time
to pause he is down material but that
White Knight on H2 will simply slide
back home to F1 and say what attack do
you really have we have seen in previous
days the black king I guess Carlson try
to do something like this slide up the
board The Rook go to its starting square
and try to deliver a Checkmate down the
H file that seems very far away but we
see with Wesley's last move that he
feels that now is the time he needs to
pounce yeah he needs to pounce then
again Knight Sarah King's best friend
and these are two very very strong
Defenders for two white Knights and
there we go one of them drops back to F1
keeping everything under control and
that's the big question I feel here is
black quick enough you're still a pawn
down more pawns to follow this Pawn
about to drop and uh yeah is this plan
quick enough it costs one move to move
the king costs two move to move the Rook
maybe uh three moves to move the Knight
and then four five to Checkmate I don't
know if you get that time
you know with this last move that
Wesley's made it looks like he's doing
everything right but once again Arjun
just blitzing out that night Retreat
again feels like he's in his preparation
you were talking about how he impressed
Wishy earlier Tata steel and that was a
preparation up to move 36. we're
currently on move 19. it was a game
against nehal Suri and the helmet one
blunder and that was all over and that
was all the way up to move 36. at this
level your prep needs to be deep some
say as deep as true love oh deeper
wasn't that in the Italian game as well
am I mistaken which opening was that one
that he prepared all the way to move 36
yeah the one again and the last move was
this small pawn move F3 which wins the
game in this end game if you haven't
looked at it you guys have to check it
out brilliant brilliant prep there and
just really nice ideas and Wesley is
going to be breathing aside relief
because For the First Time Arjun has
properly stopped to think so so maybe
not that deep because uh opening
preparation not as deep as move 36 but
it's moved 24 impressive stuff by the
way but it's either relief or fear
because sometimes when your opponent
starts thinking after all the prayers it
means you made a mistake so you
typically see the first three lines of
the engine saying these are the top
moves and then maybe Wesley's like did I
just make the fifth best move and my
position is bad but I do think we have
seen our generic I see he left his
preparation he's on his own he does have
some standard looking movies to play his
rook in the corner isn't doing much he
can slide it towards the center and I he
is up a pawn for now he should be
feeling pretty good about his chances
here and he knows that he is not just
making a simple strategic draw he is
going to fight to The Bitter End this is
the exact type of position that he
wanted and now he's got it he has a lead
in The Clock he should continue to use
the clock as a weapon that's an eight
minute lead on the clock and that's
gotta count for something the Queens are
still on the board it's a complete mess
and of course Wesley has things under
control so far but he still has some
difficult decisions coming up and one
can imagine those challenges with the
spawn structure that black has he would
need and require some time to navigate
those Waters it really looks like in a
win-on-demand situation arjun's got the
dream scenario regardless of what the
eval Bar says yeah so how much time
would you want to invest here it's a
crucial position you're finally out of
your preparation you have to think on
your own two feet how much would you
invest two three more minutes or will
you just try to get a few quick moves
down on the board to keep the pressure
on Wesley
it is very critical here for Arjun as
well as you mentioned it's very possible
that his preparation is now over and
this is New Territory for Arjun he
perhaps realizes that he needs to keep
his chances alive needs to keep the
initiative going can't trade off too
many pieces I would say another minute
or two but he needs to keep that
pressure on the clock that is absolutely
key for this match I would say another
minute David if he takes longer than
that Wesley's confidence grows and every
second that Arjun is spending to think
on the board Wesley is getting that
additional time we can see him on the
camera it's not as if he's looking
around chilling he is calculating right
now so Arjun the more time he takes the
more time Wesley gets yeah and we see
Wesley kind of a bit Restless bobbing
his head there he's calculating as you
say but also uh yeah getting a bit
excited maybe he's proud of himself
finding a move that Arjun hasn't looked
at I don't know if arjun's got
photographic memory but I'm impressed
that he's memorized to move 24 these
days I forget things by move three or
four but uh in the end playing the most
natural move a bit odd to spend almost
four minutes and then just centralize
your Rook this looked like an automatic
almost but uh yeah it makes sense Robert
just trying to get Rooks off the board I
don't think we care that we're
potentially dropping the white A2 Pawn
black isn't gonna have the time to go
and take that one so uh very logical
move how does Wesley keep the attack
going and uh he's back in the tank again
just a strong move because now he is
offering a trade of Rooks at some point
he remains upon ahead and Wesley says I
can't hold back any longer let me take
that Bishop the Knight on F1 has to take
back so for origin it's a bit confusing
to me because he either can throw in an
exchange of Rooks or just take back the
Knight with his Knight of course Knight
takes night seems like the most obvious
choice so what is he really thinking
about yeah he uh eventually makes that
decision and now a bit of calculation to
be done because one of the nights has
disappeared it was temporarily a couple
of Bishops against a couple of knights
normally you favor the Bishops but black
support down had to do something
concrete and he's banking on the fact
that White's King maybe on the back rank
might face some problems and and that
you don't really want to recapture this
bishop ever with a pawn you wreck your
own structure
but it looks like they're going to have
a fourth sequence of moves now because
with these trades now you don't want to
capture that Bishop with the pawn if you
if you do that then black picks up the
Rook on D1 and well you watch out for
that Rook on it but the Rook can go back
to d8 and you're fine the E3 Pawn is
also weakness you've kind of destroyed
your own Pawn structure so with that
black white has to trade oh wow I was
just going to say White House to trade
the Rooks first but instead Arjun says
none of that because that would just
lead to a lot of Trades and no chances
for white he does go for this ugly
looking Pawn structure but keeps pieces
on the board yeah you predicted It Again
by accident that time Tanya well done uh
I hope you really did buy a lottery
ticket after yesterday and meanwhile now
we're predicting the black Rook to drop
back Wesley pauses is he really
considering a queen trade right now uh
it would be up his alley it would be his
style but he is a pawn down so dropping
the queen back pretty much forcing the
Queens to come off is a potential option
what do you think Robert great choice
for Wesley and when he pauses that
that's when I start thinking when I
initially am anticipating is probably
wrong so I think he is going to slide
the queen back because the Queens have
to come off after Queen did it once
those Queens are off the board the A2
Pawn can actually be captured with
Queens on with heavy pieces there that
pawn do you want to capture your Bishop
can get trapped now the black Rook is
looking to slide into D2 with activity
along that file the Pawns in the center
for white are very ugly and the Knight
on G3 has nowhere to go because the
bishop on E6 is perfectly placed so wow
actually Wesley decides to keep even
more material off important he gives him
a rook that's a sacrifice he's just I
think he's supposed to draw this is just
incredible we were assuming he had to
defend his Rook move his Rook or swap
the Queens he says no just take my Rook
please he moves out of check and that's
a mark of Genius Wesley so if Rook takes
Rook now Queen takes pawn and there's
not that many squares for the king to go
to you can't go towards the center
whoops suddenly it checks in the bishop
and uh oh sorry oh that was the
announcement sorry this would be a plan
I agree Kyle just to show what white
shouldn't do but if you go the other way
if you go to the side with your King The
Black Queen drops back with a check and
either you allow a repetition which
doesn't suit the match situation for
Argent eriggaissey or you have to throw
a knight in the way but you might well
regret this after Queen takes Knight if
you do start retreating with the King
for example the pawn will move whoops
Checkmate is going to come uh two
threats here you can go forward with
your king maybe but Black's attack will
continue the White Queen is so far away
remember we've mentioned this when a
queen is divorced from a king your king
will get attacked and uh devastating
threats on board but basically it's
super easy for Argent to go wrong here
yes this is a mock of Genius what Wesley
has done just moving that King forward
calculating this line This is why Wesley
is one of the best players in the world
and once you're behind in a match it is
impossible to come back in it with this
guy I mean look at this move King G7
dictating it till the end look at Wesley
right now he knows it that he's got this
in the bag brilliant game brilliant
seriously brilliant from start to finish
because it seemed like he was out of his
book early in the preparation was up
Origins alley it was a dynamic game and
yet here we are saying the only choice
for white that doesn't lose in the spot
allows a draw by force repetition uh
Arjun he was going to look for something
he knows he doesn't have anything Wesley
so just earned himself a spot to Face
Off does he only have one move now
origin he only has one move and it's the
move we were showing even in that
variation uh it's nothing more than a
draw for white at maximum Rook takes
Rook is the only move not to resign
right now it's obvious he will play this
one after bit of thought but it's
sinking in now I generally after Rook
takes Rook as we showed Queen takes porn
forces the king to the side of the board
the Queen will yo-yo between the H6
square and the E3 E3 square and it's
just going to be a draw well there's one
more move that Arjun does have but
unfortunately for him it doesn't work
David if you just bring up the live
board one more time white Dan throw in a
check with the Knight on H5 in the
current position just to distract that
Queen from that E3 Pawn but it is the
geometry just doesn't work out for white
because black simply snaps up the Knight
if you pick up the Rook you might think
you won an exchange but that g Bond
marshes on the board G3 you're
threatening Queen H2 and very
importantly The Rook on D1 hangs as well
and in fact black is the one who comes
on top after this yeah black will be
winning if uh Audrey tries to keep going
uh the game going sorry and uh simply
nothing else to be done poor Arjun he's
played a good game he prepared really
really well but genius from Wesley so to
shut this one down and force the draw
the aid of a rook sacrifice just
incredible stuff it's G7 it's been a
Wesley so Match Game one it was a
position where he was slightly better
pressing he was able to convert that
into a full point here in game two he
showcases his excellent preparation it
seemed like only Arjun knew what he was
doing but wessis just was slowing down
because of how dangerous the position
gets if you don't play the accurate
response and we're talking about Wesley
so here maybe the most accurate player
in history among the best for sure and
he just does not make mistakes very
often that's why throughout the year so
far he's lost practically no games in
classical chess he had two wins and all
the rest draws and taught to steal and
title Tuesday he drew a couple games won
all the rest against the car Nakamura
they drew all five games but he had the
white pieces in the Armageddon and now
against our generic geissy the only
player who has beaten Magnus Carlson
here in the air things Master it's just
a Wesley so show and look at him he's
such a humble guy Wesley so but sitting
there just like oh yeah yeah and I'm
sure you know once he's it looks like
this is gonna be over really soon when
he does join us I know he's gonna have a
lot of good words for Arjun to say very
encouraging always to the younger
generation uh yeah Wesley so is perhaps
one of probably the kindest top 10
players in the world he is he's number
one he's 2900 when it comes to just
being a nice guy he's just a nice guy he
really engages in the trash talk that we
see between uh top players from time to
time and uh yeah Arjun we mentioned the
sponsorship deal he's been so good this
last 12 months but uh he'll learn from
this match and he'll move on and he'll
uh learn yeah he'll take a lot of uh
tips from it just from how Wesley's
guided this game to safety won the last
one impressive stuff by both players
I've got to say you know guys we've seen
so many amazing games so far but I have
to say for me King G7 is perhaps the
most stunning move in the whole event so
far I mean it's just such a little move
so unexpected we were looking at The
Rook retreating the queen blocking the
check but Wesley here just moves the
king up has calculated this till the end
it's just aesthetically so pleasing to
end the game like this yeah some people
ask me you know what separates the very
best from the rest of us even from other
very strong grandmas is what separates
the real elite and its moose like that
when you just have the presence of mind
to stop to realize there are
alternatives not just to play the most
obvious moves a lot of us we don't have
that impulse control we just play moves
because they look like they're forced or
they look natural uh but these top
players they uh yeah they have this
other dimension and they they see things
like this they have the imagination to
see these tactics and yeah he's surf
flowed through it's going to be a draw
and it's often said against Magnus
Carlson if you don't draw the
immediately when the draw is kind of
offered not by his hand but by the
position if you don't make it you are
likely to lose and that's what Wesley
soldiers did he figured I can make a
draw on the spot that way I don't get in
any danger and Arjun he's throwing all
his pieces forward but his King is the
one who's about to be hunted Wesley so
is not worried about the queen and the
Rook lining up right now his Queen
convention to H2 go down to the corner
give some checks win some material but
the one but in this position is if you
allow that white king to escape then the
extra material can make its presence
felt especially with the queen The Rook
lined up towards the black
yeah so let's try to find the Checkmate
the bar has gone all the way in Black's
favor now black is winning Arjun he
didn't want the draw he's falling on his
own sword here uh but how does black get
there does the check do the business it
looks like the evaluation bar reacts to
that so the most obvious move still good
for black still good enough for Wesley
uh here I was going to suggest maybe a
bishop check uh being one of the options
you could give another queen check as
well still looks very very good for
black but maybe there's something even
more effective uh I think Wesley will
jump in with the queen just because it
looks so direct you can grab a few pawns
I don't think the white king can run
away far enough from the checks you get
minimum a draw and that's good enough
for Wesley but maybe there's something
better is it to do with stopping some of
these checks preempting some of these
checks uh what do we think here in the
studio I think we've got a move already
yeah it's given a check and the King has
moved to F1 yeah it's absolutely
tempting to pick up this G2 Pawn with
the check as well you can always push
that F5 bomb the only threat that white
has is The Rook jumping onto G8 to give
a check so this is always an option to
keep things under control
looks very classy that one and the white
screen is so far away she's unable to
write to the rescue and uh yeah again I
would be just restraining myself I would
be wanting to give a check with the
queen or with the bishop to the white
king uh just to follow okay there we go
I was gonna say well let's follow
through this variation but the king
moves yes we just take another Pawn the
king can run but we continue checking it
and it's not going to run far enough uh
to save this game though David do you
see a mate here I don't see a mate but
the problem is if I keep checking you
anytime you drop back with the Rook I
can just move my queen and uh this Pawn
okay the evaluation part doesn't like
what I'm doing but uh there will be more
accurate moves yeah you could take the
Rook oh wow that's a nice one
and there we go black makes a new Queen
and this is the only way that uh Arjun
can avoid the draw we're seeing this
being played out by the way exactly the
line that you called the king is on C2
right now so a check on F2 or E2 by the
queen and then this queen sack that will
be stunning yeah that will be stunning
maybe white can pick up a few Pawns in
that variation wow we accidentally
predicted the whole picture the whole
sequence of moves you're the prophet now
in the house we all need to put on the
back for that one especially Robert when
uh Queen takes Rook happens in a moment
Arjun has nothing else to do he will
drop back his Rook if he wants to keep
this game going but then we'll see that
nice little trick from Wesley I am I am
a little confused because uh the bar is
in the middle here so is this genius by
Wesley getting the draw he needs to go
through yes or can he win this game well
he he could have won but he sees a draw
and he knows that's enough for him to go
through so it seemed that he could have
pushed his Pawn next to his King just to
take away the white threat of bringing
the Rook down the last rank but we see
he's moving his Queen back and forth and
he has secured the draw at minimum if
origen tries to avoid the draw he just
loses so I think it's just smart match
play for muscle cell yeah yeah and we've
seen it from Wesley before he's very
practical if there's even one percent
risk in another variation he won't
choose it if he can find an alternative
that removes any doubt whatsoever and
now we see the position repeat itself
have it there we go that's it Arjun had
no option it's over Wesley so takes the
match he goes through to face Hikaru
Nakamura and the loser is final to start
in 10 minutes and look at that confident
face of Wesley so how impressed are you
with him after this match Robert just
typical chess player yeah you know what
he's doing right now he's looking over
that game seeing if there are any
improvements but it was a perfect
demonstration by him withstanding the
pressure at the opening playing every
accurate move and then going after his
enemy King Wesley so is a monster and
he's earned himself a spot in division
one the next event that comes around so
he's just thriving the Champions chess
tour yep there is no doubt now we
definitely will see Wesley so Hikaru
Nakamura and Magnus Carlsen because they
will be top three in division one in the
air things monsters they have qualified
for division one in the next event but
who's going to win the tournament we
don't know that yet the grand final is
tomorrow and it's going to be either
Wesley so or Hikaru Nakamura to face
Magnus calls and the losers final will
start now in a little less
than 10 minutes and Wesley so we'll be
going into that against Hikaru Nakamura
with a bunch of confidence after this
game David yeah an incredible game to
finish off that match and uh
commiserations to our generic I see
he'll be back he'll be stronger but
today he ran into uh Wesley so in beast
mode and it was this position Wesley
initiated a trade of Rooks he captured
the white Rook white recaptured with a
nasty check and here in the studio we
were predicting a block there's two
sensible ways to block this check you
can Retreat your rook and uh Force the
White Queen away or you can force a
trade of Queens going into a very
respectable end game by sliding back but
of course Wesley had seen one step
further he'd seen a third option and he
simply moved his King this relies on a
tactic after Rook takes Rook that's uh
after Queen check the white king cannot
Escape instead we saw Arjun almost fall
on his sword there he gave away a knight
he was actually losing the game but just
trying to preserve some winning chances
Wesley however didn't allow any of that
a draw and he moves on
we're joined by Arjun Air Guys who's
given it an amazing fight in the air
things monster but now knocked out how
are you Arjun
hey um
it was a great match I think board games
were pretty close
in the 2015 maybe I should have just
taken a joy in the first game
and second one I think I
I basically taught after the victory
when Queen night is supposed to go back
but I forgot that I can move again
yeah and what a game uh that second game
by Wesley where he only needed the draw
you were in that must win uh what was
your reaction when when Wesley played uh
was it uh King to G7
yeah at that point I realized I messed
up and I don't it's always inevitable
and I just went for this pretty much out
of desperation but that didn't help
either
Arjun you put up a Really Brave fight
today one of the big highlights in this
event has been that you are the only
player so far who has defeated Magnus
here that must be a special takeaway
from this one
you have definitely the match against
Magnus was great I
the few previous matches that I played
with him were all ended in three games
so I I was quite happy that it went all
the way to uh Mega then yeah and Arjun
what's coming up next for you now what's
your plans in the near future
oh honestly I have no idea I have
nothing planned until
May so I have to see all right well we
hope to see you in the next event in the
Champions chest door thank you so much
for all the entertainment done for
joining us
thank you bye thank you Arjun and we're
actually also joined by Wesley so uh who
is very shortly going to start the
losers final against Hikaru but
congratulations on winning the match
against Arjun Wesley
yeah thank you very much thank you guys
I'm you know I'm happy to still be in
the tournament and uh I I I mean there
are a billion rules for this year's
Champions Chester but I think I qualify
for next uh for April right you are now
guaranteed division one in the next
event what does that mean to you yeah
it's huge so that's exactly what I was
fighting for today uh not necessarily
the price but to have to avoid doing the
play in because it's very tough also
I'm going to Germany on tomorrow we're
leaving
for Germany and I'm playing two
tournaments there one is in Dusseldorf
one is Berlin and our ticket is uh
scheduled to go back on March 13 which
is the exact day of the play-in so I
really wanted to avoid that one
yeah yeah it's it's big winning today
against Arjun was big yeah and and lots
of match you played especially that
second game that King G7 move are
experts in the studio are saying it's
one of the best moves of the tournament
how happy are you if you're playing that
game yeah King G7 King H7 also draws uh
yeah but I actually didn't freaking G7
until he took my Rook because I was
gonna play Queen d8 and go to the end
game and you know but King King moving
the king forces the door right away so
with uh
was very pleased I mean it can't
necessarily be the best move because I
mean the prettiest move because it only
makes a draw but actually the way Arjun
played in the end turns out black is uh
winning but I was very pleased because
Arjun is an amazing player I have a lot
of respect for him
I think Fabiano caruan also mentioned
that out of all the Indian youngsters
since Arjun has a lot tons of potential
and they could possibly reach 2800 one
day but uh
but it's nice also it's a pure Edition
like it's very good in the openings so
I'm very happy to uh you know to do well
the opening against him uh today in both
games uh well the first game I mean the
second game
I was very happy I was able to remember
my preparation because I think I pretty
much prepared it until move 24 or
something like that move 23. so I didn't
have any problems there but when he took
the pawn C6 I spent a long time
considering Bishop D7
Queen 578 H5 Knight F1 but I didn't see
anything but after Bishop E6 turns out
black has absolutely no problems so that
was all nice because whenever white
plays this Italian with Bishop G5 uh the
position gets very complex and black has
to remember a lot of things it's
dangerous for both colors
um and the first game was also very
interesting with Rook on D5 I think he
made a slight mistake with Bishop takes
Knight early on
I think the bishop on F6 was very well
based uh and then later on I think he
should have just taken the door and
repeated moves but it was very risky for
black to keep playing and I I was just
trying to find the right time to break
with F4
and so both games were very interesting
there were a lot of things to to discuss
uh and there were a lot of crucial
moments
but uh yeah it's nice
yeah Wesley congratulations on winning
this game and now there's a big final
coming up in your bracket and just
really quickly maybe you can tell us how
are you looking at this matchup against
Hikaru in this one
oh yeah I mean well he he beat me two
days ago yeah
so uh uh you know he's
I mean he's probably the favorite
because he's very good that this time
control this format
uh you know hopefully I can do better
this time I'm not sure what his strategy
will be but uh for the last two matches
against Magnus and myself he was taking
it to the Armageddon which I think is a
very good match strategy so we'll we'll
see see does the same thing today but uh
do you want to avoid the Armageddon
against Hikaru Wesley or is that a good
match strategy for you as well
yeah to be honest I would prefer to
avoid it I mean he's oh so time control
gets shorter and shorter he's uh
his Advantage gets bigger and bigger so
preferable to avoid it but in in my
match against him two days ago I didn't
really had any things substantial
uh
well you know I'll just give my best I'm
just happy to qualify for on the April
event and hopefully I can put a good
fight against uh certainly sorry to
play some good chess we're looking
forward to it Wesley it starts in only a
few minutes we really appreciate you
stopping by and talking to us before
this match against Chicago good luck
yeah wish me well yeah
all right and also Robert I want to say
thank you for the good collaboration in
the Olympian a few months ago and we'll
win the next one all right well we'll
see how you do next but congratulations
so far and thank you for those kind
words
yeah thank you
Wesley so it's getting ready for uh the
big loser is final against Hikaru
Nakamura the winner of that match we'll
make it through to tomorrow's Grand
Final to phase mine is called how cool
that he actually stopped by and talked
to us see how it starts he's such a nice
guy like you know we of course I was the
coach of the US team at the Olympiad and
so we worked together a bit and he
didn't have to just you know say that to
me but he's always just so you know kind
and he always Wishes the best for
everybody but he can't wish the best for
Hikaru he has a lot of respect for him
we heard him say when the clock ticks
Downs when the car was at his best so
we'll I think we're gonna see a fighting
Wesley so in the best of two rapid games
here it's going to be intense it starts
in a few minutes if you're not a
subscriber on Twitch we're gonna send
you now to a twitch break before it
starts
[Music]
it's an intense format this season on
the Champions chest or Wesley so only
has a few minutes to get ready for
another match the losers final is best
out of two games and if they are tied
then it will be decided in Armageddon
Hikaru Nakamura is in there because he
lost yesterday's winners final against
Magnus Carlsen and Wesley predicted
David that Hikaru wants to take this to
Armageddon what do you think what will
this match be like it's so hard to call
Kaya both of them are unbeaten we can't
forget that neither of them have uh been
hit in this Tournament Sunday just that
one match between them was decided by
Armageddon it was so close Hikaru got
black in that which was decisive
eventually
I still think Armageddon is 50 50. it's
about who gets the black pieces it's
about the psychology of the bidding war
and uh I do have a feeling that that
will decide it it's just too hard to
separate them yeah and I was going to
ask Wesley what his strategy is going to
be in terms of bidding if you learn
anything from Magnus yesterday and his
own bidding against a car the day before
but I felt he might answer the question
and that's bad for his match strategy I
didn't want you know hikar to listen and
hear it so Wesley being such a kind
person he wouldn't have left me on red
so I feel like you know it's better not
to ask him let his actions do the
talking yeah and he did say he wants to
avoid the Armageddon Wesley so let's
take a look at the bracket this is day
four in the air things monsters we
started out with quarterfinals on Monday
four players made it through to the
winners semi-finals and uh for players
were knocked down to the losers bracket
we did have a winners final yesterday
between Magnus Carlsen and Hikaru
Nakamura Magnus Carlsen won that in a
dramatic take Armageddon to make it
through to tomorrow's Grand Final we
will now follow follow the losers final
between Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so
best out of two rapid games with 15
minutes plus three seconds increments
and if they are tight it will go down to
Armageddon Santana what do you think
Hikaru has been doing today do you think
he's been following Wesley do you think
he's been preparing what has the car
been up to you mean if he's not been
streaming or or maybe he has been maybe
he's been streaming I think but if he's
not he's definitely been keeping an eye
on that match and thinking about his own
strategy as well Hikaru would love a
rematch against Magnus but of course uh
so would Wesley we've been talking about
how this double elimination bracket is
such a good showcase for the best
players to show their ability and here
we've got the three favorites who've
actually the heavyweights will qualified
for the next tournament and the fight is
amongst them Magnus Hikaru and west see
this is what we dream of from a
tournament I think Wesley made a really
good point by the way I want to say that
I can't imagine any other chess player
doing what he did to just come and talk
so openly about what the match that he
had but also his Outlook towards what's
coming up it was just incredible to get
his thoughts so much appreciated and I
think when he said that he wants to
avoid the Armageddon I think that makes
sense for Wesley yeah Wesley will try
and settle this one in the rapid all
right oh they have faced each other a
bunch of times Hikaru knock him around
Wesley so both playing for the US it is
in favor of Hikaru does that mean he's
also a favorite in this match Robert
well lately it's turned around in
Wesley's favor we did see akaro take him
down in Armageddon the other day but
that Global Championship that earned
Wesley has spot through to division one
the air things master that was one on
the biggest stage by Wesley so that was
an eight game match five to three in
Wesley's favor he's proven that he he
can take down Hikaru history says the
car was the favorite Wesley says the car
was the favorite but today is a new day
and maybe Wesley can come with his best
stuff and take down akaru like he has in
the place yeah he's definitely coming
with confidence after some fantastic
play against Arjun Eric icy Hikaru
Nakamura is ready
and what do you think David what do you
expect from the first game well it looks
like Hikaru starting with white despite
uh him being cool
talking of great hair quality Hikaru
looks slick gotta say hi but uh yeah
we're off it's uh E4 E5 it's a Spanish
Mo I'm guessing just judging but from
recent history between these two but uh
okay actually wow Hikaru is black we got
that one a bit wrong so I was gonna say
if a car route starts with the white
pieces he has the advantage but no it's
the Italian game this is what Wesley has
been going to it's his go-to opening of
course we saw him on the black side of
this opening uh in the last game between
him and Arjun but yeah this has still
been seen before between these two uh
Giants and really interesting here that
Wesley actually switches it up now he
played the Spanish against Arjun when he
started with the white pieces and now he
starts with the Italian because he's
pretty clear hikaru's been watching that
match so Hikaru would have been prepared
to face that he goes to the Italian but
of course that said Italian is no big
surprise for Hikaru that is another
opening that he was expecting uh very
important that this is just a two-game
match so once again the result of this
is going to be critical Hikaru will try
to neutralize uh Wesley's advantage of
having the white pieces and look at this
he goes for a very Dynamic idea of
hitting that F2 weakness moves this king
sidesteps with the king and the whole
plan for black here is to get that F5
break in David you want to strike in the
center you want to open it up with F5
one gets the feeling Kaya you were
asking what has Hikaru been up to so far
this morning I think he's been looking
at this line okay and this is really
positive for us as fans because Wesley
first of all avoided the Spanish
therefore avoiding the Berlin Wall
therefore avoiding a quick draw so he
show showing his aggressive intentions
he wants to win with white and Hikaru
avoiding what he went for two days ago
against Wesley this uh maybe solid but
passive approach would which did lead to
a couple of draws I'm slightly surprised
to see the Black Knight retreat in this
fact in this fashion I thought it was
going back another way just to show
Tanya's point there black did have a
very aggressive approach available to
him if he had recruited the Knight to a
different Square it does look odd we say
Knights on the rim are dim this Knight
can also be eliminated by a white Bishop
but that will come at the cost of the
bishop pair the most important idea here
is just throw this Pawn forward blast
open a file because uh we've talked
about this bishop in the previous game
same opening remember this bishop
extremely stronger than that on the
diagonal so why not open up a rook
towards this Target on F2 as well and
this would be a really committal
decision hikara says no he goes back in
the other direction and after Wesley
develops don't be surprised if Hikaru at
some point moves this night again just
to get that pawn moving get the Rook
motoring behind it but now it's back to
a more maneuvering battle perhaps I'll
this last couple of times but it feels
like white was handed a couple free
turns right because you went Knight out
to G4 and then Knight back H3 that pawn
pushed for white is a movie you want to
play anyway a black put the king in the
corner to play F5 and now can't play F5
because the knight's in the way so this
seems like something went wrong for a
car in the opening uh not that he's that
much worse in the current position but
even his facial expression was like huh
uh what's going on here and he didn't go
for the most testing at least the most
tactical possibility and said he drops
back and Wesley should be slightly
better The Rook on A2 later can slide
even towards the center or you can
double on the queen side if you feel
that you can open up the position I like
the start of this game for Wesley so
yeah and one thematic plan would be to
drop the White Knight back and reroute
it to a very solid Square in front of
the white king looks uh really nice what
you've got to say Hikaru if he has
slipped up in the in the move order in
the opening he would just be like the
rest of us the number of times I've
messed up the move order in the Italian
game from the white side from the black
side and con count is just too many it's
so hard to understand all these little
differences these little nuances but uh
looks good for Wesley he has dropped his
Knight back
see because
we made the night jump forward that he
wanted to blast open with that F Bond
but then coming in the way of his own
plan with this nitrate Retreat slightly
strange decisions there and now he takes
a think now you were mentioning this is
a thematic idea what black also can do
in these positions is to challenge that
light squared Bishop that white has on
C4 making a developing move himself
Bishop to E6 because what you really
want to do what you wanted to do with
that pawn push that we were talking
about is open up the f file so at the
cost stuff even doubling up your pawns
let's say after that Bishop trade David
if the bishop was to land on E6 and
white was to trade these Bishops you're
happy with the spawn structure because
you managed to open up that f file yep
your Rook is open and you do have extra
Central support these pawns might look a
bit ugly they might look a bit weak long
term but for now they control all of
these Central squares so uh that will be
the most logical move in this position I
feel but uh slightly inconsistent
perhaps with his previous few turns and
uh Hikaru is thinking the time issue not
so drastic yet but he needs to come up
with a plan if not going for this bishop
trade he might well find himself cramped
I don't see what else he would be doing
here I think I understand where hikara
went wrong we're talking about uh kind
of subtleties in the opening and when we
make inaccuracies if we just go back to
the moment before Wesley went before
just very quickly a very common move is
that Knight going up to A3 instead of
the pawn push to B4 and now after Knight
G4 white has to slide The Rook up to E2
defend the F2 upon and the King slides
the corn like hikard in the game and
after H3 I'm pretty sure there's a move
F5 so tactically it's just a wild
position and I think that this is in
preparation still where black gets the
open file and creates an attack so I
think that Hikaru maybe mixed up his
lines didn't realize that once uh Wesley
pushed the pawn on the queen side it
opened up the second rank for his other
Rook his more a passive rook and that is
what has led Wesley to get the upper
hand in the opening because the car had
to backtrack it wasn't the end of the
world but it's a clear Plus in my eyes
in my estimation for Wesley so yeah
definitely and it looks vaguely
symmetrical right now especially with
these Knights these two proud Black
Knights mirroring the white counterparts
but this black king in the corner isn't
necessarily that well placed and uh
White is the first one to break in the
center either now or maybe on the next
move first you could uh just slide back
with your Bishop make sure there's no
attacks against it this is a very
typical idea I've had it in myself
plenty times against ferrugia for
example but uh next white will just
occupy the center and what does black do
in the meantime the reason I say the
black king isn't actually well placed in
the corner it's because you want to
centralize your Rook you often want to
move your Rook here but suddenly this
Pawn would be loose so it feels like not
just as Hikaru lost two moves but he's
given white moves for free he's given
white uh plenty of options and okay
Wesley doesn't go for that instead he
brings his Queen to this to the square
highlighting the fact that this F7 Pawn
isn't defended sufficiently
and now that other plan that we were
talking about has also been snatched
away from Hikaru no more neutralizing
this light Square Bishop by offering a
trade the queen on B3 doesn't only hit
the F7 Pawn but also stops any of future
trades or development well one of the
things that black can do to insist on
that is move the queen One Step Ahead
Queen to E7 you defend that F7 Pawn
you're also in the future wanting to
really trade off these Bishops because
it is the key in White's position it is
really one of the strongest minor pieces
that white has so Bishop E6 has to I
feel David arrived on the board at some
point yeah this does however give Wesley
one move to open up to control the
center and this would be slightly
awkward for black potentially yes you
can still offer a trade but maybe some
different consequences Hikaru chooses a
different Square let's wait to see the
Fallout from that one but it looks like
the same idea it's the same idea but a
nice subtlety because I just realized
that after Queen E7 there was a nasty
little move that white had which could
be the knight jump to F5 you hit that
Queen underneath stubborn and usually
black wants to trade these Knights but
take a look at the position that we have
Bishop F5 EF5 and now because of the
King on on the Square that it is the
queen on the Square that it is the
Knight on G6 is actually trapped you
can't jump it to F4 because then white
just picks up that Knight and watch out
for that pin along the e-file you can't
recapture it and I think that's why
Precision here by Hikaru choosing the E8
Square yeah very nice so he's created an
Escape Route for his Knight also hinting
that he might throw this Pawn forward to
try and trap this white Bishop I
wouldn't be surprised though if Wesley
either takes the time out to prevent
that idea by uh pushing his Pawn forward
allowing on person if B5 ever happens or
goes for a central break Let's uh allow
Wesley some time to think of that
decision uh how about you guys I know
the Italian game is maybe the opening I
struggle with most in terms of memory in
terms of understanding the ideas uh what
are your least favorite openings the one
says them in the French defense I had
those ready I thought I'd make you pause
for Thought brother why why don't you
like those openings actually the London
system for the same reason uh I think
maybe David in the Italian because if we
look at the current position not a
single piece has been traded not one and
so you're kind of just maneuvering
around trying to find the best squares
and then you don't know is it too soon
to push a pawn is that going to create a
weakness and Wesley did just push his
pawn and this was just trying to open up
the board for his pieces he is a bit
ahead in terms of space and development
uh but that's why I don't like the
London the French your Bishop is
terrible it's buried behind uh the pawns
the light score Bishop for black is just
a miserable piece and I can never back
the French defense even though yes I
have played it before I used against
Vision
I feel like the Italian I don't mind
playing against it but the London I
absolutely hate and the reason for that
is that I think it's the kind of opening
that you don't expect will ever be
dangerous for you but then somehow it
always goes wrong I have the worst score
against London I probably shouldn't be
seeing this tonight
opponents are preparing right now
all right well you did see something
cool on the screen uh just now the
tournament trophy uh every tournament
will have a look at that how nice is
that every tournament will have a unique
nft trophy by a unique artist and you
can actually get this trophy it's up for
bidding on chesschamps.io or you can use
the QR code scan that with your phone
and go in and make your bed for that
very cool trophy wait so I can bid for
the show yeah it looks like it's from
the new Harry Potter game or something
yeah it looks really cool like the
Quidditch cup
Harry Potter fan uh Loosely not really
okay okay like the tri-wizard trophy
that's the one oh sorry yesterday was
Pokemon
over there oh yeah
I think everyone knows that now yeah
yeah if you haven't that's on you if you
haven't read Harry Potter exactly right
if you haven't seen or read Harry Potter
by now well
you should was it in the first book that
they had to play a chess game too yeah
yeah it was and Magnus Carlsen remembers
uh every move in that just came we
tested him in that one we tested him and
I would I just put a position on the
board I was like what's this from and he
guessed it was Harry Potter and he was
like okay the Knight moved here that
means the night must be wrong uh the
queen you know must be this one and
Harry must have been the bishop to
deliver Checkmate yeah another level of
uh brainy yeah yeah not the level of
memory wizard chess and is there
anything magical about this position
that we are seeing right now after 18
moves in the first game here I'm not
sure magical's the one but uh at least
Wesley's gaining space pushing forward
with his pawns I slightly prefer the
white position uh what about you guys
sir I think yes White House space but
that's so typical and classical of uh
the Italian opening that white does
manage to get this control over the
center we see it also in Spanish that
white has the space Advantage but black
really wants to do to neutralize that is
exactly what Hikaru is doing try and
trade up as many pieces the last piece
is on the board the less you'll feel
cramped because when you're behind on
Space you don't have that much uh those
many squares to jump around with your
own Army so you really want to try and
minimize that feel that lack of well not
having fresh air at least on the board
and look at this last move of Hikaru
hinting at exactly that he moves the
bishop as well out of the way and wants
to get a rook trade-in as well
if those Rooks leave the board on the
open a file I don't feel that Wesley has
enough ammunition to really cause
problems for Hikaru yeah it definitely
feels like every trade that happens the
closer black gets towards the desired
result towards equality uh do you see
anything here Robert that Wesley can try
to keep some tension and keep some hopes
I think he's gonna have to trade at
least one pair of rocks along the a file
and maybe he's gonna have to go after
the C7 Pawn as Queen is in line with
that pawn uh the F7 Pawn we've talked
about because the king steps at the
corner that means The Rook needs to stay
with its attention on it so it's gonna
be a fight for the only open file Rooks
need open lines it's about that a file
so if Wesley can make use of that he
should be the side and with the
advantage I also like that his Queen is
the more active of the two but I just
want to give hikara some credit really
quickly because he slipped in the
opening I really do think that he
misremembered his lines not that it was
a too terrible a position but it was
worse for him and he just makes these
good moves quickly after that so I I'm
very impressed by the way this position
has churned from one clearly better for
Wesley to just kind of like this might
be a handshake soon yeah at least a
small strategic threat potentially of
capturing a pawn because for example if
black plays a lazy move a quiet move uh
actually maybe not that one but after a
trade of Pawns then suddenly white could
double up the black pawns on the B file
by capturing this bishop the reason I
say not that one is because suddenly
actually the black queen is quite well
placed the queen trade would be
comfortable here for black it's just
really weird I always find it awkward as
well in this opening how were the
Knights just stare down at each other
it's never clear which one you can move
it's like a kind of stare off between
them I can't move my Knights because my
pawns might drop you can't move your
Knights because your pawns might drop
and it's just uh yeah they cancel each
other out so in this position not too
much to worry about for black but with
this last move Bishop to E3 as you're
pointing out in this current position at
least white Knights are just slightly
slightly better than Black's Knights and
the reason I say that is David because
look at that F5 Square the White Knight
can actually jump to that square and
because the light Square Bishops have
been traded off there is no piece to
charge challenge that meanwhile uh black
snide on G6 doesn't have that freedom it
doesn't have that flexibility yet to
arrive on F4 because of that Bishop in
E3 which is why I think the bishop
trades in the line that you were
pointing at uh would actually be great
for black because then black also gets
the option to jump in with the Knight
and I like your idea of putting that
Queen on C8 just a it's a strange move
and a strange Square because you're also
giving up the a file at some point but
it's sort of prophylactic it's it's
looking into the future and saying you
know what this is what you want but on
my terms yeah I I must uh admit hit
Tanya I was showing this as an example
of a bad movement and suddenly I
accidentally stumbled across maybe one
of the most logical and uh yeah exactly
Hikaru Nakamura here he's got a bunch of
options you can't move this Rook because
it's tied down defending upon you don't
really want to move these Knights you
don't want to move your Bishop you could
make an argument for moving the king
back but then you feel a bit silly
having lost a couple of moves uh having
put it in the corner earlier so process
of elimination this is what I do a lot
in chess if I don't know what to look
for uh then I just look at all my pieces
I talked to you no none of you can move
apart from the queen so I'm expecting
the queen uh to get busy and maybe just
slide across you could make an argument
for jumping in but uh okay Hikaru goes
all the way back with this queen where
she came from very solid square and uh
just very solid position for both and
the reason that he's done that is
because the queen from here is actually
eyeing that B Pawn as well uh so right
now all these trades that we were
pointing out the queen on it will do a
good job of not only hitting the B5 Pawn
but also the central E4 Pawn so a nice
square and once again the ball is in
Wesley's Court Robert what do you do you
trade off on E5 hoping to get the
Bishops off and try and Destroy Black's
Pawn structure I feel like Wesley's the
type player who just Maneuvers around a
bunch he finds she's little improving
move it's kind of carpovian Anatoly Corp
of the former world champion was well
regarded for his ability in very locked
positions just to reroute his pieces so
I feel like Wesley he thrives in that
situation if he feels like he has
absolutely nothing he can just swap the
pieces off and say I'm ever so slightly
better take that as a bit of a mental
Edge but I do feel like this position is
so solid for Hikaru uh he made this last
one Queen d8 he's just shiring up his
position and as Tanya said eyeing that
B5 Pawn in case the White Queen is any
funny idea so I don't really see too
much in the way of an advantage for
white anymore with the liquidation with
the pieces getting traded I think that
makes hikaru's task more and more simple
yeah I just love what Hikaru has done
he's defended everything he's just
locked things down he's uh especially
with this last move he said okay no
threats for you no promising captions
for you you find a plan you burn time on
the clock trying to solve all these
problems or at least trying to create
something out of nothing and I'll just
sit here happily wait for you to make
that decision and then I'll pounce and
then I'll counter if you go wrong and
that's why he wins so many Blitz rapid
tournaments and that's why he's so good
at speeches Hikaru because he nearly
never blunders but he always pounces
when you gets a chance and he gets these
positions where he's ready to react it's
a very reactive style but a very
effective Style
remember you can always reach us either
on Twitter using the hashtag chess
Champs or in the twitch chat I see a
bunch of comments coming in super nice
to see that if you do have any questions
for our excellent experts here in the
studio then share them on Twitter or in
the twitch chat and we'll bring up as
many as we can
you know we've been discussing in this
position the idea of White's Knight
actually jumping forward and I think
that is something that black needs to
watch out for but first Wesley decides
to sidestep with the queen to be for and
is he perhaps hinting at some kind of a
pawn at once all the way up to C4 and
then to C5 trying to block that Bishop
are there any tactical ideas along the
A3 f8 diagonal I can you know one can
get the feeling that something is being
set up here yeah something's being set
up but it's very mysterious I'm going to
say uh Tanya and he played that move
Wesley he kind of leaned back shook his
head frowned for a second and then
recomposed himself
I'm curious what the idea is as well and
maybe just positioning his Queen on a
slightly better Square recovers the dark
squares
um you mentioned this poor idea of
pushing white supawns forward that's on
the cards certainly but Hikaru just
solidifies things even further he's like
a rock right now uh how are you going to
erode this structure for black how are
you going to break him down
I wouldn't want to have this position as
white uh wanting to win uh of course
Wesley's not in that must win situation
but
your car is so solid you called him a
rock so he's like Onyx is what you're
saying you need to find the water just
trying to get through here but I see
nothing I mean that moved Knight D7 it
makes sure that all of the bases are
covered some of the earlier variations
we were talking about was with a trait
of the dark Square Bishops black queen
Side Pawn structure could be shattered
now the 997 also protects that Bishop
just in case and we see Wesley he moves
his Knight back as well and that's the
benefit of his position he has a little
bit more space that Knight heading up
the board to C4 a knight on D7 it's
dominated by a pawn three squares away I
love to make mention of it and it
actually is important here that white is
just a teeny bit more active Tanya had
been focusing on the night on G3 which
still can land on F5 at any given moment
but that night on it wasn't F3 slides
back to D2 up to C4 and maybe that's the
small benefit of Wesley's position the
small little nagging advantage that will
cause Hikaru some trouble oh Knight's
jumping all over the board look at that
last move Hikari says you go back with
the Knight I come forward with mine
Knight H4 yeah I'm not sure exactly what
that does but it does it does scare us a
little bit it does scare us a little bit
and it does deter this idea of knights
F5 that will simply be traded off I just
love how uh Wesley's moved the queen
before move earlier vacated the C4
Square really mysterious but the idea
was two or three moves uh two or three
players we say uh just in the future the
Knight now leaping forward I'm expecting
Wesley to play that very quickly why not
and uh at least pose a question to
Hikaru uh here it's like Onyx bind bind
just create that bind and uh yeah
hopefully uh from Wesley's point of view
you don't allow black to break out but
uh of course Hikaru will be waiting for
that punch like Hitmonchan and just
ready to uh too many Pokemon I'll stop
that now but uh he'll be waiting to
break out punch his way out of this one
if given the opportunity maybe the idea
he didn't get it in earlier remember he
wants to play for F5 but uh maybe it's
on the cards either now or on the next
few moves I would love to see F5 on the
board we've been talking about it since
the start of the game and even if it
comes now it will have big questions to
Wesley how is he going to respond in the
center if this Pawn break comes through
and knowing Hikaru he's not going to shy
away from it that is exactly what he's
thinking about the pawn move all the way
up to squares hitting that E4 pawn and
Wesley about five minutes and things are
getting tricky Kaya oh but talking about
big questions we have a great question
on the Twitter from Matt asking you guys
have the commentators played each other
before Oh we did actually just a couple
of days
but have you played in like a tournament
or something like that no either of you
no really have you guys played against
me no no wow okay I've I haven't played
in the US that much I must say and I
love Madden Grand Swiss we played in the
same tournament I think we even sat two
boards apart once but uh no not against
each other we Dodge each other that's
why we remain on such good terms we need
to make that happen or should we avoid
it
you know I don't play very much so I'm
happy to not play chess but I think that
both Wesley I mean look at this position
that we just had we actually had a huge
change because after the move F5 Wesley
took that pawn a car did not take back
he said brings his Queen out and now the
question is will hikar just regain that
pawn will he be fine here uh but I think
that Wesley he has an opportunity as a
tactical shot uh look at that Knight on
H4 they say loose pieces drop off
there's a queen on B4 and there are many
pieces in a row on that fourth rank but
if that Knight takes the bishop first
we're about to see the line clear out
that the Knight takes back for black and
then you push the pawn up to D5 that
Knight on H4 is under attack the Knight
on B6 is under attack from the bishop
things are getting spicy wow that's
great full board Vision I've got to say
Roberts and uh it's not visually obvious
at first so it might take Wesley some
time to spot but this is really annoying
this Knight is hit of course it can step
back and recatch the pawn regain the
material balance but after a bunch of
Trades I'm not sure which one you take
first but for example just this line
suddenly white is the only one who can
win because you have the superior
structure also in positions where it's
just major Pieces Just the heavy pieces
such as queens and Rooks Pawn shelter is
all important and for example white hair
can centralize defending this key F2
Pawn from any threats you have more
shelter than the opponent therefore you
have the advantage also easy Targets on
the queen side this is really uh really
sneaky stuff Robert and if he finds it
it feels like vikaru is on the back foot
Wesley will play a risk-free position
his dream uh the style of Chess he loves
to play and uh he might well get close
to that win I don't think Hikaru will be
loving his position if that is played
but it's very difficult to see that you
can kind of clear the whole fourth rank
in one blue and will he find it
and then to be able to also evaluate at
that last position that we had on the
board really offers big chances because
let's not forget guys that actually the
next game Hikaru starts with the white
pieces so if this one ends in a draw
with everything being traded off and
white isn't able to find something big
in that position to really fight for uh
Hikaru well one he can easily take it to
to the Armageddon something that Wesley
wants to avoid and there we have it
Robert your idea on the board so Wesley
not only having great well the car
missed it look at a car's face
he looked to the side he was oh what is
that and he realizes that now he is
going to face a terrible ending while
Queen and Rooks on the board but a
horrible Pawn structure that was a
missed shot from Hikaru yeah huge Miss
and uh we're going to end up in that
position we predicted and it's only
white who can win just take those
Knights off the board I'm not sure if
you have anything better here but uh
just lock it down it's all about white
in that position more active Queen more
active Rook better Pawn structure safer
King and uh if you're Wesley so you will
hope that all of those things add up to
an advantage of course the material is
disappearing from the board the drawing
margins will be quite high in general
but uh it's all about Wesley so and
Hikaru he was shocked but he's
recomposed himself this is another thing
that sets him apart at the very top of
World Chess him Magnus Carlson Wesley
they all recover from setbacks so
quickly even if they miss a move they
recover and they just continue playing
chess he's so adaptive to this situation
then we have spoken about that before
that's one of his biggest Trends is just
how resourceful he is he doesn't really
dwell on what's happened for too long
that little headshake that we saw in
that said he's done with it he's ready
for this new position this new challenge
but very impressive by Wesley to spot
this idea Robert that you were
mentioning especially the geometry of
the Knight hanging on H4 and you call
this action out it is on the board uh
there's one thing that works in Black's
favor is that the queen on F5 and The
Rook on f8 they do I the F2 Pawn as well
as the other Central Pawn which is a
weakness so black also has a few trumps
the one thing that black needs to watch
out for in this position with White
Queen centralized imagine if the Rook
joins the attack goes all the way to the
seventh rank Rook coming into E7
threatening a mate in one on G7 and you
don't want to allow that yeah so there
is at least one thread on the board as
Tanya points out you don't have time to
for example push a pawn because White's
Rook will land and of course the
Checkmate threat but also Targets on the
other flank so I'm expecting Hikaru to
do something quite energetic here not
sure exactly what to be honest but uh he
needs to do something now the other
Potential Threat will be taking his Pawn
if the black queen moves away and uh
yeah I wouldn't like to be Hikaru he's
looking really really calm uh it's like
that Taylor Swift song just shake it off
and uh he's looking really relaxed but I
would be panicking I've got to say as
black it looks fantastic for a white
because a queen trade that won't solve
all of Black's problems either the pawn
structure is so bad that white may be
able to pick off the pawns or tie
Black's Rook down in a resulting end
game to the defense of those pawns that
is not what you want so that's what
hikar was thinking about meanwhile with
the Queens remaining on the board it
wasn't my step up with his Rook yes
rookie seven is an idea but he can bring
his work to E6 he can bring it up to E4
push his Pawn F2 to F3 and just cement
the position there are no weaknesses in
White's Camp so I think that this is
super unpleasant to play at the highest
level because Wesley so he typically
punishes people against our generic
geissi there was one mistake by Arjun
down the stretch of the end game he made
Argent pay the full price that full
point was Westies that's the reason he's
here facing a car yeah I do it go on
down I was gonna say I love it Robert
just either one of these Rook moves
rookie for rookie six uh Tanya which one
would you be I was thinking about the
third one about the idea that we were
talking about coming in for the mating
threat with rookie seven but I think
what Hikaru has in mind is to challenge
that Rook you don't want it to stay
alive for too long bring that Rook up to
F7 stop that mate offer a rook trade and
this is how he plans to defend this
position if the Rooks do get traded
after Rook F7 the queen picks it up
White Queen can pick up a Pawn on the
left side of the board but then black
gets a Central Pawn and everything is
under control and I was just thinking
you're absolutely right that uh Hikaru
looks like he has in fact shaken it off
as you said because he believes that
Haters Gonna Hate and players gonna play
he's feeling 22. uh just like the age of
quiet time today oh yes thank you oh hi
I'm the problem it's me so you know we
can all throw on our t-swift references
but this just looks great for Wesley I
mean there's no risk whatsoever whether
he wins this game is another question
but he can push his Pawns he can bring
his King up the thing about this is that
white is essentially up a pawn black has
two B pawns those both of them are
stopped by one white Pawn on B5 that's
why we typically don't like double pawns
they're not the end of the world early
stages but in the end game it's like
you're just down upon despite the
material equality so this is what Wesley
is hoping for to move his pawns forward
bring his King up but will it be enough
because as soon as you push your pawns
your king gets exposed to a bunch of
checks and the black king is tucked away
in the corner yeah and we should also
mention that Wesley can't try and Bully
Hikaru here with a threat of a queen
exchange if the Queen's ever disappear
white will be winning King opponent
games because as Robert mentioned that
structure for black those two I was
gonna say two become one they don't
really become one those two are canceled
out by the one on the B file so uh
definitely all about Wesley here can he
finish it off can he convert this
extremely difficult but uh he'll be
loving his position this is right up his
alley as we mentioned
um this is Wesley so's uh wheelhouse
this is what he loves to do just grind
down his opponents in risk-free
positions
very impressive it was looking super
drawish just uh not too long ago and
Wesley has been yeah look at the bar
here
if you'd asked me to guess five moves
for black David I would not have thought
about G5 in that position no me neither
I've got to admit and uh okay the
evaluation bus stays there meaning that
White's Advantage is actually long term
that black made oh then it drops so
maybe Matt Black made a tactical mistake
but Wesley didn't pounce on it
immediately I'm not sure exactly what
that was maybe it was some way to try
and force the Queens off the board but I
didn't spot it Wesley didn't spot it and
both players are around the two minute
Mark now so we might see those
occasional swings but Queen end games
Precision is so difficult every move
white will have 10 possible Queen moves
but uh often only one of them will be
strong so from a human point of view
extremely hard to Guess that and okay he
gives a couple of checks White Queen is
centralized as well that's what you want
in Queen nine games look at the White
Queen she controls the whole board The
Black Queen very passive only
controlling a few squares so so
Advantage weight but not winning yet
it's going to take a lot of work and I'm
going to ask you guys put you guys on a
spot too predict the results right now
in this one
I'll choose the one that you don't
choose Robert I'll let you have the
first first pick and pick a draw I think
that the yeah I think the white king
will be a little bit too exposed because
what Wesley wants to do is create a pass
Pawn we've talked about this if you cut
the board you look at this various pawns
the three the two pawns for black on the
beef out stop by one white pod the F2
Pawn which is right next to the king it
can push two squares forward but as soon
as you do that your king becomes
vulnerable to checks from the other side
and we see that Hikaru he brings his
Queen back a square going after the pawn
on D5 so it's hard for white to both
defend that pawn and allow himself to
push his F Pawn forward so I just don't
think he has enough in this position to
get a win yeah I'll go for a win for
white but uh reluctantly cool draw but
uh yeah we'll see I do believe in
Wesley's conversion chances against
anyone in the world other than maybe
Magnus Carlson and Hikaru Nakamura and
that's the uh that's the kind of really
uh Elite uh competition he has to face
here that he has to break down
these really yeah incredible Heights the
aster scale but first he's offering a
queen trade and you have to say no if
you're Hikaru Nakamura I think because
uh White support structure is superior
queen and king opponent games will favor
white you have to say no but also you
have to be careful where you move that
Queen to uh David because just imagine
you know you want to give a check on
that Central Square so you decide you
know what I'm just gonna sidestep it all
the way to G7 so I can land on E5 next
and guess what happens then it's just a
meet in one with Queen F5 that would be
game over so of course Hikaru knows what
he's doing he declines the queen trade
very important Point Robert you made
earlier that all kingpong endings are or
at least should be winning for White and
the Queens have to stay on the board
Queenie 8 also comes in with the idea of
centralizing it to E5 and that's kind of
a square you want it on yeah I suddenly
see Robert being very interested in this
position for white it looks like some
nasty Queen checks essentially yeah I'm
just trying to see like can I somewhat
offer Queen trade uh but if the King
goes if you're Queen E6 it's one of the
ideas I'm trying to figure out the
Queens are swapped then I was feeling
like black wins this Pawn on E6 but
maybe even though black is going up upon
a material white is going to still be
the side with the advantage because you
go F4 this is crazy you take it we King
takes back you take on E6 black goes up
a pawn but it's actually losing your
extra Pawn is on the D file white has
the outside Pawn it's a distraction the
black king will have to scoot over the
white king will swoop in win first the
d-pawn then the both of the B pawns and
win the game that's how end games often
go with just king of Pawns yeah and
actually those B pawns they're basically
the same as one it's on the board wow
okay Wesley so banking on this king of
Pawn game being winning Hikaru is going
to have to calculate really well here he
did he did he dodged it and I think he
was right to do so so still very solid
for black still defending this Pawn
hinting and jumping in with some counter
checks can Wesley win his Queen is
getting in now wow this one it feels
like it should be really promising but
uh not quite winning yet for Wesley so
and both players now under at the minute
Mark around 40 seconds each this one is
going to be a race can Hikaru hold it's
not going to be easy for him it really
feels like it's hanging by a thread for
black and Hikaru absolutely precise here
declines the queen trade the fact that
he could one upon in the King Pawn
ending and still it would be lost goes
on to show that no matter what he cannot
afford to trade queens and there Wesley
not repeating with the check but now it
just feels like a karus queen has
managed to get active
yeah and as soon as White's Queen gets
greedy and starts taking some pawns on
the wrong flank on the queen side The
Black Queen will have all the time in
the world to deliver a bunch of Nazi
check uh Nazi checks so it looks like we
might get a repetition we might get it
yeah second time we've seen that
position okay Wesley plays on this is
promising that's what we'd like to see
he's looking for his chances he drops
the queen back Hikaru has to be careful
where he puts the black king if the
black king lands on the wrong Square we
could see a queen exchange on White's
terms so Hikaru is still with some
questions to answer what could be a
wrong Square
um if the king comes forward on maybe
onto the f file shifts towards the
center at some point you've got to time
it right but the White Queen
like now oh could he have swapped
Queen's there saw it immediately
it's a draw they've repeated the
position three times did Wesley have a
win on that final move just before he
agreed to draw I'm gonna check this but
both players seem to miss that white
could have traded off the queens and
Hikaru reacted Wesley could have won
it's confirmed he could have won if he
didn't trade the Queens off what the
final move was it blunder by Wesley so
has not reacted we saw a big reaction on
Hikaru shingoff
draw do you think Wesley knows he had a
win here I mean as soon as the game ends
and you see the game analysis he knows
it was winning but yeah you know it
looks like he's just trying to keep
himself composed and Wesley is second to
none at doing that I'm just waiting for
the reaction I feel like that's it
yeah he's just keeping a poker face
right now he doesn't want to give it
away and there we have it that was the
moment that was hikaru's Reaction game
one in the loser final ends with a draw
Hikaru Nakamura will have the white
pieces in the second game David show us
what was this I'm so shocked Kaya
because just as an instructor's point I
was saying don't allow a queen trade
that's the only way you lose his
position is black and Hikaru
all right he just missed it and uh
Wesley so trusted him Wesley so didn't
even look to try and punish his opponent
and it was in this position it's still a
draw the position has almost repeated
itself a few times and Hikaru maybe
relaxed one move too early he brought
his King to the f file and Caillou
asking this question how can we win this
game that's by trading Queens Robert's
mentioned it before any Queen end game
uh any king of boarding game sorry once
the Queen's disappear is winning for
white and white could have simply move
the queen across this is a pin the
Queens are disappearing from the board
and there's no way to save this one for
black if the Queens come off the white
king is first to reach the center and
next move you create a poor majority on
the king side you have three versus two
and it's an easy win black could try and
spin that in a few different ways try to
defend but it would have been helpless
hopeless he would have lost the game so
just one move by Wesley so offering that
Queen trade would have won the game
instead he repeated with a check and it
was a draw
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything this chapter
is about
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
92 of games get to this position from
this position white is winning about 60
70 of the time and I think if you learn
these lines that very easily could be 75
or 80 for you
[Music]
drama drama drama I'd say for in the
area of things Monsters game two the
final rapid game between Hikaru and
Wesley is coming up very shortly if
you're not a subscriber here is a twitch
break
[Music]
whoa Wesley so could have taken the lead
but it ends with a draw dramatic yeah
absolutely dramatic
we're completely unexpected as well I
mean I did wonder why hikara's reaction
and maybe he wasn't called Mouse lip but
we'll find out now uh later on but uh
talking about drama that's not being the
only drama because there has been many
exciting things happening in division
two and division three aha so starting
with division two the Winner's uh
portion
Fabiano faced off against you Yang Yi
and we you know the first game went for
fabi's way you know he just paid
excellent chess and game three actually
saw a little bit of a turnaround because
you Yankee kind of switched his tactics
and he really started to push Fabiana
caruana right to the edge and just when
it was looking promising he made a
critical mistake and you know you cannot
make a mistake against these 28 2700
super Grand Masters and that was it his
tournament is over and uh well like he's
going to the nudism bracket I forgot
about double elimination but Fabiana
caruana he is on top of the winners
bracket and uh sadly he's ready for the
Grand Final Fabiano carono yeah he is
ready for the Grand Final and sadly we
also had to say goodbye to Vladimir
bid too low in the Armageddon and found
himself with two little time yeah the
winner of the vision two will qualify
for division one in event two there's
also a big Grand Final going on today in
division three pragnananda and some
Savion is it finished no they're still
playing their fourth game but I mean
there it was just insane I have to say
first game was just wild I haven't seen
a game like that ever but in second game
with the black pieces Sam Sabian just
struck back with such powerful chess and
uh the third game was very tense very
cagey very long drawn out and now
they're playing game four and anything
can happen wow wow wow what a cool day
upstairs in the air things Masters game
two final rapid game and the losers
final between Wesley and Hikaru is
coming up in just a few minutes
we're off it's the Italian game this is
what Wesley has been going to it's his
go-to opening I do feel like this
position is so solid for Hikaru and
there we have it the car missed it look
at the car's face he looked to the side
he was oh what is that and he realizes
that now he is going to face a terrible
ending while Queen and Rooks on the
board but a horrible Pawn structure that
was a missed shot from Hikaru
wow what is your reaction to just how
that game ended Robert well it was
sturdy defense for a car for a very long
time so for Wesley he didn't have too
much time remaining I feel like he
thought the draw was inevitable but
that's why you never stop calculating
for Wesley he should have paused hey
Carl realized that only after his move
he could have emit a mouse slip but you
need to make the most of your changes
because they don't come often against
akara Nakamura so if you would have
paused for only 5-10 seconds would he
have seen it do you think absolutely
because the king and the queen were in
the same line he could offered the queen
trade he knew the king of pawning games
are good for him I think he just thought
the draw was in the bag and he just said
let's go to game two wow and it's gonna
be game two it is best attitude here on
the losers bracket so if we have a
winner in this game then that player
will make it through to tomorrow's Grand
Final to face off against Magnus Carlsen
if it is a draw then this match will be
decided in Armageddon and Tonya now
Hikaru Nakamura will have the white
pieces what should we expect from game
two okay I'm still thinking about what
we just said I am absolutely shocked
it's your birthday but that Hikaru
literally just gifted the game to uh
Wesley in one move and Wesley just
declined the gift instead he just
repeated I can't believe it I've never
seen anything like that and now this
just means not only fighting Hikaru with
the black pieces but also fighting your
own mind yeah because Wesley knows what
he missed and that's gonna be hard to
overcome our mentally hard is that David
it's incredibly hard I was praising
these players for shaking it off
forgetting things but that was
elementary stuff that was uh that will
play on both their minds for sure and
now I think the big question is is
Hikaru after recovering from that shock
is he going to play a real game or are
we going to get another Berlin draw are
we going to go straight to Armageddon to
decide it just give those players uh a
bit more time to recover to relax and
um I do feel that has been hikara's
strategy throughout the tournament he's
done it twice both against Wesley and
Magnus and I think it's likely again
just uh it would be understandable very
understandable here just because uh yeah
he needs to get over that one moment
that one movement yeah we did hear
Wesley predict that before the match
started that Hikaru would try to go for
the Armageddon is that what you think as
well Robert I can not support Charles
Barkley but I guarantee it I think that
Nakamura he does it before the fans he
wants this to go to Armageddon he thinks
it's good content Wesley so not even at
the board right now he just sits back
and I think we will see that Berlin
repetition
okay so uh blinking you miss it this one
might be over soon and we should be five
on the water's happening guys it's going
to happen but I think this time probably
Wesley's had a shift in his mind and
there it is but David it is on the board
the check and back and check and back
and checking back and that's it yo-yo
between the queens and it's over we have
a draw we're going to Armageddon we are
going to armaged on you guys and we do
love that game two is a uh super quick
draw between Hikaru and Wesley and that
means 10 minutes they're now gonna make
their bids and decide this match in
Armageddon wow okay so we're not
surprised
that is kind of fun though it's your
birthday wishes we get Armageddon yes we
do all right so what what do you expect
now Robert now they're gonna start
thinking about their bids what will be
the bids from these two now I think
Hikaru is gonna go lower than he did
against Magnus because uh Wesley he's
gonna see that match he really wants the
black pieces he hasn't struggled against
a car over the board I mean he's never
really had a disadvantage but you don't
want to go too low so you're talking
eight and a half minutes Hikaru is so
dangerous and yesterday with white
against Magnus he really did almost make
Magnus pay he went down to the wire so I
think that hikar really really wants
black but Wesley has to be careful not
to go too low on the clock do you agree
Tanya they both want the black pieces a
hundred percent and it is all about once
again finding that balance with the
clock and wanting the black pieces
because you also don't want to get
flagged you need to have enough time
whoever is the player who does play with
white is definitely going to do
everything to have a storm on the board
so you want that time to be able to
overcome those difficult questions once
again because this was such a quick draw
I think for Wesley to overcome what
happened in game one is also something
he needs to fight a little he mentioned
at the start Kaya that he doesn't he
would prefer to not take it to the
Armageddon but I think after what we
just saw he's also sort of fine with it
because he kind of didn't want to fight
that game too much with the black pieces
Hikaru was sticking to his strategy he
doesn't care he he's got a tunnel vision
on this the man comes with a plan and he
stands for it yeah it seems Hikaru
really has a plan for his bids here he's
really calculating uh he has good reason
behind his bids what do you think about
Wesley how is what is his strategy do
you think well it feels like Wesley
would be okay with any scenario to be
honest but he will be he would have been
thinking about it more over the last few
days he will have seen that uh that
crazy bid between Magnus and Hikaru he
knows that if Hikaru is willing to play
with under nine minutes against Magnus
he's going to be willing to play under
nine minutes against Wesley as well and
Wesley just has to weigh up in his mind
is he happy with eight and a half
minutes maybe as Robert says against
Hikaru taking black or is he going to
just say okay I'll take the white pieces
I'll have a six minute advantage and I
will punish you because he nearly did
punish Nakamura in game one of the day I
do wonder if we'll see like 8 minutes 58
it's 8 minutes 57 this time or a few
seconds lower just as the Mind Games
happen guys I'm predicting an eight
minute somewhere in the eight to eight
and a half bracket here all right I
think it's playing with fire because we
did see in game one that Wesley with the
white pieces he can get an advantage and
he almost won with equal time on the
clock so I really don't think you can go
too low but Hikaru we know his Mouse
speed he's the bullet chess champion
he's been the top rated player in the
site for so many years he will take that
risk and at the end that he can say I
did it for the fans it's gonna be so
exciting you guys uh we are waiting for
the bids to come in and we'll be back
right after this
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all right
foreign
[Music]
we're gonna take a twitch break if
you're not a subscriber if you are a
subscriber while we're building up to
the big Armageddon
foreign
[Music]
still waiting for the bids to come in
from Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so what
will be their bids for the Armageddon to
decide the loser is final and who goes
through to face Magnus Carlsen and
tomorrow's Grand Final while we wait
we're gonna hear uh from some of the top
players in the world before the
tournament started we met them in VI
concert where they were playing the
total steel tournament and asked them
who they think will be the top players
in the Champions chess tour this season
if I can ask you to write how you think
the top five overall standings in
Champions Chester will look like this
season is alireza playing or is it into
fashion now should I put myself yeah
okay
[Music]
okay I'll go with Magnus okay first one
is a long name
my mother is watching us I have to be
careful
you know what I can be confident no I
can put my name
okay you know I just beaten Magnus here
in Arkansas I'm returning my favor there
returning a favor to good old friend
so you have Nakamura on top what is that
yeah he's just been like winning all his
events whenever I see him play he wins
so he's probably gonna take this one as
well um dink has bad internet so he he
is left out
I just put myself in the middle
yeah
your handwriting is very nice
that's all that's your only bet yeah
[Music]
Magnus Carlsen is super confident uh his
only bet myself on the tourist standings
2023 he will play the grand final
tomorrow and he will play against either
Wesley so or Hikaru Nakamura they are
getting ready for Armageddon in the
losers final we are waiting for their
bids to come in
and just to remind everyone Robert what
are the regulations for the Armageddon
especially the bidding process that is
kind of new to chess a new day the
regulations have not changed so the
players have a base time of 15 minutes
you bid as low as you want and the
player with the lower bin gets to choose
their color they typically choose the
black pieces and they start with that
amount of time so if I bid eight minutes
and you bid 10 I get the eight minutes
the black pieces that I'll choose and I
get draw odds so if you do not win you
do not go on so that's where the rub is
you need to win with the white pieces
and yesterday we saw where Magnus go as
low as 8 minutes and 58 seconds Hikaru
went as low as 8 minutes and 50. nine
seconds and that was low you guys
thought that was very low that is almost
on the limit on how low you can go well
I don't know how good they are at limbo
but it does seem like they're willing to
play with fire in terms of the clock I
think hikara being so Speedy he's okay
with it Wesley I can't see him going
that low on time against someone like a
car Nakamura do you think Hikaru will go
lower than he did yesterday though David
I think so as Robert said for the memes
for the fans for the entertainment but
also for his chances I do believe having
black just the way he's been playing
it's a big bonus it means that he can
react this goes for both players just
reacting is so much easier uh in Blitz
chest in Armageddon chess especially
when your nerves are high so whoever
gets black I think is still the favorite
as long as they have over eight eight
and a half minutes but uh either way
it's going to be exciting stuff it's
gonna be a race against the clock for
whoever gets black definitely definitely
um we have some news from division three
Sam sevillion has uh won the Grand Final
against pragnananda and is the winner of
division three sending huge
congratulations to uh Sam for winning
that
here we have it some Savion the winner
of uh the Grand Final in division three
that's been a tough fight with uh how
many players 32 players was in division
three and uh Prague an amazing player
losing in the Grand Final to Sam
the Grand Final in division one is
coming up tomorrow Magnus Carlsen is uh
waiting for either Wesley Seoul or
Hikaru Nakamura to join him in that
final it will be decided here in
Armageddon we are waiting for the bids
to come in
I'm so excited for it I just what will
it be
we can just sit back and relax because
either ways it's going to be an
incredible final and uh I think in just
a few moments Kyle we're gonna find out
uh Hikaru Wesley thinking and I see a
smile so they know each other's bit and
it looks like Wesley might I don't know
why I get the feeling but hey Carl might
I want the bed this is probably them
seeing each other's bits that means we
will get them
very shortly big smile on Wesley's face
again was there only one second in it I
don't know the answer but I'm guessing
so and I think Wesley is the happier of
the two which likely means he gets the
black pieces yeah you think so just
based on the reaction there and we will
not see a quick Berlin draw that's for
sure uh but either way Wesley finally
has a smile on his face after game one
you know he was having to control
himself he was upset of missing a big
advantage in a winning end game but we
see Wesley he's typically stoic he is as
good as anyone at keeping calm
yeah wow I'm impatient to find out I
can't wait I can't wait I I mean I saw
Wesley smile but it almost looked like
it was an amuse smile like just a missed
one and I felt that did Hikaru win that
win that by just a small margin is he
just laughing at how bad the situation
is right now I don't know what's going
on here the color looks really focused
it's like in uh business mode there he
looks determined to win and uh just
taking a last break before the game
starts Wesley needs to compose himself
by the way well main part of it is that
hikara hasn't really played a game with
the white piece against Wesley every
time he gets the first move he makes
this short draw so if he does in fact
have white and he's a play for a win he
needs to come up with an opening because
every time he is set across the board
from Wesley he forces that draw that is
not acceptable in this arm again guys I
think hikaru's won the bid I I don't
know why but I'm really getting the
feeling that Hikaru gets to pick the
color it's probably a debate in chat
right now who won the bids
I want to know too we're guessing here
in the studio it's just pure speculation
but uh chat what do you think yeah I
don't know
here we go
eight minutes and 24 seconds hikara
Nakamura eight minutes and five seconds
that means Hikaru wins the bid he
chooses the black uh pieces eight
minutes and five seconds guys I also got
the time right I said between 18 and a
half and I could just feel it from
Wesley's reaction that it was a closed
bed and her car was the one which means
Hikaru is perhaps gonna start with black
now and uh Wesley with 15 minutes the
pressure is on Wesley so we'll have the
white pieces he will have to win this
game to make it to the Grand Final
Hikaru with eight minutes and five
seconds and again something's happen
what's going on Hikaru with his
signature handres yeah he doesn't look
fully composed yet Hikaru of course he's
in business mode he knows it's a race
and uh okay they're off it's all about
the mouth skills now and it's the scotch
wow something that Wesley knows a lot
about you mentioned this on the previous
days Robert something happened here
what's going on with it why he is
annoyed about something maybe he's
annoyed at facing the scotch I mean it's
not something he gets to see every day
Wesley so has played this even in
classical events at the elite level so
it can't be a complete surprise but
Bishop D3 here that's not something
we're used to seeing oftentimes white
pushes the C Pawn to kick the Knight out
of the center but Bishop D3 I think this
is an Armageddon surprise yeah also
Hikaru launching the first surprise
Black's Knight coming into the center
maybe not the uh recommended antidote
normally black kind of creates a pin on
the e-file with the Queens a lot of
vocal tension there lots of theory of
course but both players trying to get
out of that theoretical battle now this
is far from anything we've seen uh
between these two before at least in
this tournament and both players
thinking at an early stage both out of
books seemingly at least Wesley already
burning 40 seconds on his clock normally
you just trade off pawns here get
castled but things would start
disappearing from the board over already
one set of knights have left more pawns
uh getting traded decent position for
curry you would think and David you're
absolutely right this move Bishop D3 is
something that's not very common to move
the pawn from C2 goes to C4 hits that
Knight in the center already and that
would be Mainline Theory but instead
Wesley springing this quick surprise but
Hikaru playing quick because he has
gambled quite a bit to get the black
pieces I mean an eight minute five
second bid that is playing with fire but
why is Wesley spending so much time here
I feel like you your clock is your
biggest asset and he's really thinking
quite a long time now his advantage on
the clock will remain it's so much time
to gamble for a car knock more almost
seven minutes to start with uh but
here's a bunch of options he can just
take the pawn as he finally has done but
I think he needs to make these moves
quickly that's what hit car did so well
yesterday against Magnus it didn't quite
work out but he was playing instantly in
most turns and what a car Nakamura says
usually is the best advice play good
moves quickly rather than the perfect
move slowly I think Wesley needs to take
that advice right now
Scotch this early
it's commented in the twitch chat it's
late in Norway it is a good time for
Scotch so it's a good time for scotch
and meanwhile again Wesley hesitating
pausing just get that white king to
safety Castle the king what could be
more natural it definitely feels like
the nerves or the momentous occasion
it's playing on his mind and uh okay and
that's what he was thinking about David
because this is an interesting option he
takes advantage of the fact that Hikaru
did not capture with the bishop
developing a piece or recapture that
bond with the queen and he is attacking
that D5 Knight black skin is still in
the center now one can be like wait a
second Hikaru can pin that Bishop a very
tempting option you move your queen to
E7 because White's King is also in the
center but that is when Wesley says I
don't care I'm going to go Castle on the
right side of the board and now sure
come on pick up my bishop and watch out
for your king in the center rookie one
pins and wins the queen Falls and this
is the idea that Wesley was looking at
now guys he's got a win on demand every
capture on the board is where he's going
to take his time he took his time to
pick up that pawn on D6 he took his time
to go for the most combative option with
the bishop to E4 and we see the drawback
with this move Hikaru says I'm ready for
a fight doesn't care about that pawn in
the center develops his Bishop stops
White's King from getting to safety yeah
talking of competence this is really
really harassing stuff already he car
retrieves from the most aggressive move
the most ambitious move even though he
only needs a draw now white can win a
pawn you can capture this Pawn in the
center for free seemingly but your king
will be stuck for a long time and as
long as you can defend against threats
such as this check for black then you
will have a long-term initiative the
bishop pair and White Castle kingside so
really creative stuff and uh okay he
played it after not that much thought
Hikaru so the time Advantage slowly
slipping away what do we think of this I
love it I've got to say this last move
by Hikaru I love the move by Hikaru but
I love the type of position for Wesley's
so you need something full of life and
this position is not easy to figure out
so a car made a very interesting last
move but look at the Pawns in the center
even if you don't take it right away
because that does give black time to uh
maybe give the king a check maybe bring
the Rook towards the center and go after
White's undeveloped Camp I feel like
that's a long-term problem and for her
car it's not going to be easy to solve
and I think that's exactly what Wesley
needs to keep pieces on the board keep
the problems there and he says let me
just grab the pawn right away no issues
from Wesley so's perspective it's going
all out and I love it I love this
approach of not backing down he can't
afford to be solid in this game he picks
up that extra material Hikaru moved the
Rook attacking the pawn Wesley defends
it developing his own piece of course
the king is still stuck in the center
but not for long uh David he can look at
an idea of going long Castle
on the other side of the board but again
that will come with its own set of
dangers yeah he's uh not just looking at
it I think he's going to go for it Tanya
and it's more out of necessity than
anything that white king is never caused
on King's side the bishop cuts across
the board like a race of that and uh as
soon as he gets given just one more move
Wesley so he's gonna Castle on the long
side he's going to say come at me and
he's going to hope that his extra porn
he can nurse it to Victory it does look
like the white Bishop has a nice home in
the center of the board as well he'll
try and neutralize Black start Square
Bishop Black's Bishop pair but if he
does so he's a pawn up he's five minutes
up still on the clock big Advantage I
fear for Hikaru now yeah it's a really
nice move Bishop E3 because the black
dark Square Bishop would like to slide
one square forward in the diagonal to go
after the Knight but the problem is the
white Bishop will slide in its path off
for a trade trades do not help black in
this position so Bishop F6 will be met
with Bishop D4 the white king will
safely castle queenside in the near
future and I just get the sense that for
Hikaru his Warrior about the fact that
he's not going to have a big attack on
the queen side when you are lacking in
pawns you have open files that's the
good news for black Rooks but if you
Castle kingside it takes a while for
your f8 Rook to jump on over to the B8
square and if that Rook did land on the
Queen's head then we'll be talking some
serious Firepower for black that's
several moves away the queen and the
Rook have to get out of the path I think
it's just a little bit too slow it's a
little bit too slow indeed and uh okay
he speeds things up by attacking that
White Queen but the White Queen will
happily slide back the bishop will sit
on this nice Central post that we've
highlighted and White's King should
still feel relatively cozy comfortable
on the queen side up to Hikaru now
pressures on him I mentioned that having
black and Armageddon it's nice when you
can play reactive chess you could just
play quick moves you don't have to
calculate too much but he can't react
anymore he's a pawn down the onus the
burden is on him and he's down more than
five minutes now of course which doesn't
help at all okay he's activating his
Queen Hikaru nice move there very
logical and for at least one move white
cannot Castle on Queen's side because
watch out for that A2 pawn it will be
hanging if white decides to get his King
safety at this point so currently kings
are still in the center black is
threatening to Castle kingside on the
very next move and white Skin's still
struggling there so there is some
compensation as long as Hikaru can make
sure that the king doesn't get to safety
yeah and uh Wesley so with a big
decision now but he does have time in
the bank this is a good point to invest
a minute or two just to try and figure
out how to get that white king to safety
as Tanya mentions and uh critical moment
Hikaru will be looking for ways to
continue just annoying probing against
that White Queen side if the white king
does end up there and uh yeah I've got
to say just this is lived up to
expectations this Armageddon game this
is uh really fascinating to watch I'm
glad we're seeing a proper chess game no
more interest don't want to see that
Bollinger ever again and it's only just
starting because look at hikaru's clock
just over five minutes Wesley has now
dipped under 10 but something that's a
problem in her car's position is even if
he wins up Pawn back his pawns are split
on the queen side so if Wesley can trade
the queens that doesn't just simplify
matters at all Wesley will have a
long-term nagging advantage and we could
see that in the next few moves I
actually think there's some potential
variations where Wesley for example
Castle's Queen side here if you play
Bishop takes A2 maybe the move Knight D5
look at the Queens they're staring at
each other and if you think you're just
going to trade Queens on D2 and we'll
enter an equal end game not so fast the
pawn on A7 it's already targeted the
Knight on D5 is super strong the pawn on
D6 is super weak and white will slide
the next Rook over the D file this is a
long-term advantage that Wesley could
win in a classical game of chess with
even time but with hikar down to nearly
five minutes on the clock you do not
want to have this ending Yeah the more I
look at it uh Robert there the stronger
this move appears just Castle Queen side
bite the bullet you have to be very
brave you have to calculate things
correctly but if you can get away with
it meeting this Pawn capture with the
night jump then you've got to go for it
you might not give get given another
opportunity to Castle that side it is
very brave I do wonder what happens if
black keeps the Queens on for example
all you need to do is move this bishop
out the way and then dive in with the
queen to A1 this would be Checkmate so
it's very risky but if you can get away
with it you should do it now and uh
Wesley still thinking suddenly only a
three minute advantage
time is ticking and Hikaru will be
gaining in confidence every second that
ticks away yep he uh we'll be in the
Grand Final with a draw in this game
Hikaru Nakamura five minutes and 19
seconds left on the clock no increment
in Armageddon Wesley Zoe has to win this
game and his clock is ticking now down
to eight minutes is he spending too much
time absolutely I think he's taking way
too much time because he needs to keep
the pressure live on the clock he has to
take a decision one way or the other
whether he decides to give up that pawn
and go for the lines that David and
Robert have been mentioning or make
another move but it's also hard to come
up with an alternative here you guys
have been talking about bringing the
dark Square Bishop to the center of the
board and I think that's another idea
that Wesley is looking at just shifting
this Bishop from E3 to D4 eyeing that
pawn on the king side the G7 Pawn but
whatever Wesley does he has to do it
quick he can't lose his time Advantage
here yeah let's see what stockfish
suggests uh potentially just how wide is
the margin for error here for white uh
how much can you go wrong but still keep
it within manageable bounds and okay wow
it did suggest pawns A3 stockfish the
best move giving over one point
Advantage for white simply because
White's one Pawn up and uh Wesley does
eventually find the best move but it did
come at the cost of nearly five minutes
on the clock long long think and now
stockfish saying okay black has a bunch
of moves maybe the best is to push black
Central Pawn forward these guys are so
good they keep playing the best move but
uh is it enough it still thinks stopfish
that white has the advantage and uh is
now the time to Castle Queen side it
looks just as risky as before I've got
to say but uh the computer says yes you
can get away with it black has ideas of
sacrificing pieces opening up the
position around the white king pawns
will be vulnerable on that left side but
uh he's got to calculate he's got to
decide quick where's Lisa dude I have to
show an absolutely crazy line while you
were talking I was thinking whether this
works or not and I think it does if you
go long Castle
guess what what what's on my mind right
now the fact that you say it's crazy
means it's a cool sacrifice it is a cool
sacrifice but it is a queen sacrifice
and let's take take a look at this can
Queen A3 be a reality because if you
pick up the queen I give a check you
sidestep with the king I give another
check with my Rook I've got three pieces
in the attack I still don't see a mate
but I think we're getting closer King to
A1 is the only move I jump in with my
Bishop give another check you've got
only one square left I pick up that
Knight
you don't need to Checkmate Tanya you
only need the drawers black so you can
keep repeating moves you can keep
checking the white King For Eternity no
way the white king can hide from the
rook and the combined might of the
Bishops I'm so disappointed it's not a
mate though wow yeah I mean it might be
who knows but Hikaru won't even look for
a mate he'll take the draw and get out
of here and that variation was scary
enough for Wesley so to retreat his
Knight but that's a really sad move to
play Not only have you put the Knight on
a terrible square but you've also got in
the way of your idea of Castle in
queenside and at least he's gaining a
Tempo however with the queen trade
threat and I have called Wesley so
karpovian what he's trying to do is move
his Bishop to the D4 Square then break
his Knight that was on C3 up to the E3
Square get that pesky Bishop out of C4
and the 93 protects C2 so you are more
likely to Castle queenside because
you're Bishop on D4 protects the B2 Pawn
the Knight protects the C2 Pawn I feel
like Wesley has done some really nice
maneuvering here but a car reacting very
quickly as well playing for the attack
yeah playing for the attack so now these
black bishops have really uh getting
their money's worth they're really doing
a good job this is a nasty pin but if
Wesley gets a move or two to shuffle
into the corner he'll feel very very
safe now and uh okay Hikaru has that
luxury it's only one minute in it can he
whip up an attack can he get those black
Rooks active big questions here to
answer for both sides this one could go
either way on the board on the clock
still Advantage Wesley but not by much
anymore he does Shuffle into the corner
now that white king is in safety and
white does have that extra pawn and that
beautiful Bishop on D4 really not only
defending his own the queen side the
long Castle but also eyeing black skin
on G7 gives Wesley the hope to launch a
king side attack and that's what he's
done and Hikaru taking this opportunity
to at least go in for an opposite color
Bishop position now if pieces do end up
getting traded it can very well end in a
draw as the Bishops are not of the same
color and those positions are super
famous for uh you know even with extra
material often just being a drop but I'm
expecting Wesley to keep all the pieces
on the board try and create an attack on
hikaru's King because that's where the
chance is White's Bishop cannot be
challenged and that's the key your queen
jumps onto G5 you hit that pawn on G7
you're already threatening a mate in
this position Wesley looking for an
attack yeah and Hikaru looking very
proud of himself nodding his head that
this last move a very clever one I
really like it just putting his Pawn on
F6 just neutralizing any threats that
the white Bishop can create against the
black king once those threats have been
neutralized Hikaru can go about the job
of just trading off the Rooks trading
off the Queens there we go one set of
Rooks have Potter from the board if the
Rooks and queens disappear very likely
to be a drawer but uh opposite color
Bishops only one good thing in Wesley's
back pocket he's up a pawn and where is
that pawn it currently sits on B2 so at
some point he's trying to pushed that
pawn to B3 and spring free a pass Pawn
opposite colored Bishop end games with
just bishop and pawns known for their
tendency to be a draw however if you can
get an outside pass Pawn you distract
Black's pieces they have to deal with
that and then you can focus on the other
side of the board so Wesley he is
slightly better he is up a pawn he's
also still ahead but almost a minute on
the clock but this is where his car is
at his best he plays these moves so fast
he finds the strategies I just think
it's really truly difficult even if the
time had an hour on the clock for each
wow and now Hikaru hits two pawns that
was the h-bound hanging and the g the
only way to defend it is what Wesley has
played the queen jumps further and now
he's threatening background threat so
don't get greedy with the queen Wesley
if he starts approaching the queen Side
Pawn it can very well end in disaster
with a check on the back rank he falls
back first eyeing the H5 Pawn instead
and now big decision guys does black
trade off the Queens it's very committal
you can bring the black queen down to F1
on the first rank that's a pin just like
Wesley missed actually in the previous
game you forced the trade of Queens it's
opposite color Bishops but then as
Robert mentions the white porn start
running Hikaru says no can't allow the
white pawns to move and this is a really
nice Square for the black queen she's
always centralizing is good but she's
eyeing up those white pawns on the
diagonal and uh very very difficult for
Wesley to actually make progress he can
move his Bishop around but the white
king not entirely safe I feel like
Hikaru is playing extremely well right
now yeah and it's hard for Wesley to
make any Headway still a minute in it
but uh okay second time we've seen this
position now Wesley can't repeat he
can't go for the draw and it just feels
like black species are so active right
now the queen and the bishop ship and as
long as they stay alive Hikaru creates
his chances and not trading the Queens a
great idea but I also like what Wesley's
doing he's bringing the third piece into
the game it happens to be the king and
we might see the King march up the board
all the way starting to attack the ace
the A4 Pawn Yeah and Hikaru is terrified
of a potential King match by white he
drops the black queen here we go come on
Wesley so bring that King forward ask
those questions and if you're Hikaru
you're panicking right now because that
white king is going to support the
advance of the that white poor majority
on the queen side yeah and the queen
trade will not end in a draw we keep
talking about this opposite color Bishop
he usually means High chances for the
draw not here with white king very
active and there goes the bee Pawn now
your spring for your password do not
take it that's why car brings his Bishop
back he does not want to allow connected
past pawns but look at Wesley so inching
in with the queen Nexus King is coming
up to B4 he is kicking Black's pieces
back and I feel like he has great
winning chances uh I was gonna say yes
Hikaru come on bring the black king
forward bring the black king forward on
the king side but he's just waiting now
but uh the waiting game is not going to
help too much suddenly you're getting
overwhelmed on this queen side it's
three pieces against two Black's King is
just a innocent bystander here and does
Wesley take another Pawn take it and her
car was shaking his head he hates his
position he hates what he's trying to
defend although I see just falls back
with the King now remember there's no
increment here so repetition makes no
sense I'm surprised he didn't pick up
that a second free free porn he's going
backwards that's the wrong direction the
white king is super safe here yes but it
was doing such a good job bleeding from
the front but the time Wesley so is an
experienced bullet player we know how
good it Karo is Wesley he's no slouch
either so he's using the clock as a
weapon because if they're both spending
a few seconds per turn that's good news
for Wesley because at some point Hikaru
may not be able to find the correct
continuation with just under a minute on
his clock which is where we're heading
yeah that's actually very clever that's
a really relevant Point uh Robert you're
just going to maneuver on the dark
squares you can pretty much pre-move the
next few turns for Wesley and uh only
when you reach that kind of 40 50 move
mark uh then you push a point then you
commit and then the counter starts to
Fresh play on that 50 move rule don't
necessarily need to rush to make any
progress and oh wow another offer of a
trade of coins this is confident stuff
from Wesley I would not be 100 confident
this is when uh the winning this this uh
queenless end game but he's asking that
question look how her car is burning
time having to decide Queen trade or no
Queen trade and the status quo
maintained the clocks are ticking I wish
amazing chess right now every move
placing a piece on the dark Square just
keeping up the pressure offering a queen
trade at the right time he does it again
hikarus made up his mind that no matter
what he's not going into an end game
here and it's
Wesley slowly and suddenly improving his
peace position the queen has landed on
D6 a G4 break in the air so dangerous on
both sides now but F3 that was not timed
correctly by Wesley because look at the
black queen it's ready to jump into the
board if that pawn captures back on B3
so that was an inopportune moment for
Western with this King which is not what
you want you want connected pawns and
Hikaru is immediately going for the
attack on the C2 Pawn he's jumping and
you don't have time to pick up the D5
Pawn the F3 Pawn that you pointed out
badly timed is also hanging yeah
suddenly it's turned around we saw
Hikaru do his uh trademark head Bob
there he knows that he's fought back and
now he can just give a couple of checks
where's this white king gonna hide the
black queen can come back where she came
from I up some of those weak white pawns
on the king's side and at first he
activates his King I love to see it King
of the Hill here both Kings advancing
but uh still the clock the biggest
Factor 40 seconds in it now Wesley
retreating he's lost control suddenly
not so easy look how the black queen is
just causing a nuisance from behind here
so many weaknesses in Wesley's camp and
the King's got nowhere to hide the white
king which looked absolutely safe is now
just running Helter Skelter big
ger from checks black meanwhile has
sidestepped any threats along that pin
that it was there and King G6 is a super
nice Square Hikaru Nakamura needs just a
draw and it looks like Wesley might have
missed a huge opportunity his head
Wesley now it's only 15 seconds in it
but he needs to be Shameless that's the
problem that Wesley is having right now
he needs to go for the flag it may be
called dirty it's whatever go for the
time and now he's doing it but he's
giving up some pawns and Hikaru is
really not down the clock at all it's a
pure bullet game at this point I mean a
little over a minute per side and there
are no problems for black anymore
stormwork is asking in the twitch chat
can Wesley simply flag Hikaru not
anymore yeah at this point it's Hikaru
trying to flag Wesley it's basically
level on the clock and actually if
anything hikaru's position is easier to
play look at this he's just gobbling up
horns black has the more dangerous
passport and Black's H Pawn is going to
start running any moment Wesley on the
defensive on the board and now not in
charge on the clock anymore I I would
pick black here I've got to say and you
can see in his body language he knows it
and Wesley there shaking his head he's
attacking the bishop Hikaru gives a
check first the king moves forward that
H5 Pawn is going to be a big distraction
and now he says I'm ready for an end
game because he's got a passer of his
own the queen turns a force there's no
way that white can avoid it without just
losing the game on the spot that's why
hikaru's world of saves we're in the end
game white has these outside pass pawns
but look at Black's H Pawn that one is
running up the board very fast it's
helped out it's gonna be escorted by the
black king and the other pawns this is
just easy for a hit card right now and
he's even ahead on time right he doesn't
have any problems whatsoever yeah looks
like black is completely winning the
race even without Black's three pawns
this is still actually a draw so uh
Hikaru he knows he's got this in the bag
he's smiling he's got a Time advantage
and he clinches his fist Wesley resigns
wow it's uh over Hikaru Nakamura makes
it through to the Grand Final he will
face off against Magnus Carlsen tomorrow
again winning here in Armageddon look at
that t-car Nakamura what a beast he is
and uh this
four months incredible is he Frozen or I
think he was frozen there but we'll see
the fist bumper the fist pump any moment
now Wesley meanwhile shaking his head he
knows this it was a missed opportunity
he had a pawn Advantage he had a few
minutes Advantage but the car too good
yeah how impressed are you Robert with
Hikaru Nakamura it was amazing because
he was defending accurately but I
thought Wesley was actually going to
flag Hikaru he's playing every accurate
move into one little slip and the car
doesn't hesitate he realizes a mistake
and he's able to secure an equal
position and then he's just much better
and unless he had no choice but to tip
his King over yeah is it down to
experience from Hikaru just having done
this so many times in online chess what
I don't think Wesley's done it anytime
less I think Hikaru really believes in
his abilities when it comes to the
Armageddon which of course he's up
against Wesley is also super duper
strong in these kind of moments and it
was amazing to see Wesley create his
chances with this game with the white
pieces I think it all came down I saw
him marching up with the King and I was
like Wesley's got this he's doing all
the right things he realized the queen
trade works for him but then just one
missed opportunity and we keep saying
this Kaya that Hikaru is so hard to beat
in these positions you give him one
chance to come back the guy does it
super super resilient super resourceful
and that's what saved the day for him
today yeah and he's ready for the Grand
Final we're joined by Hikaru Nakamura
big big congratulations
ah thank you yeah it was a very uh
interesting match let's put it that way
yeah and what is your take on what
happened in the end here in the
Armageddon
yeah I mean obviously after yesterday I
wanted to bid low just to ensure that I
got black
um and I did get it but I think I mean
my bid my bid was probably okay but the
opening that I played was very shaky um
not so much in that it was uh that it
wasn't playable but it was a very double
edged position where I can win or I can
lose
um because I'm sacking a pawn and when
you're in that situation and you're down
on the clock it's really not optimal
um and I suspect I was okay at some
point
um after I sacked the pawn but with like
eight minutes you kind of have to just
go you can't really think too long and
Wesley was definitely better
um I don't know if he was ever winning I
mean it was also very tricky because
there were multiple times that I could
go into a bishops of opposite color end
game but I wasn't really sure whether
that's a draw or whether I'm losing or
what's going on so I rejected that
um and then yeah he made this one
mistake uh when he allowed me to take on
B3 with the queen to E2 chuck if he
doesn't do this I think there's still a
very good chances he wins that being
said I had my optimal setup already
where I'm guarding the pawn on A4 he
can't really push B4 C4 without the
pawns getting blockaded
um so it would have been on Wesley to to
prove it but he he had chances for sure
but one blunder was was too much how
scientific do you get when making your
bids in the Armageddon Hikaru
yeah I mean I don't think it's about
being scientific I think it's the one
Wesley and I play we're both extremely
solid I mean for the most part we played
the exact same openings with both colors
um and and so I just want to be black no
matter what I mean I thought about going
even lower than I bid I mean I thought
about going below eight but I mean at
some point you you have to feel like if
your opponent outbids you it's what it
is like you just play with the white
pieces you take the time advantage and
try to win as opposed to being like
being really really clever I mean
yesterday Magnus and I got got it down
to like sub nine minutes and actually a
funny funny tidbit is that on the um on
the first day when I played uh or the
first match against Wesley when I made
my bid the guy at chess.com when I when
I wrote like 928 I think it was he's
like are you sure it's 15 it's a 15
minute game and it was kind of funny
because obviously everyone is bidding
well below 10 now so I mean I think what
I bid today was was definitely very much
on the edge I find it hard to believe
you can go much lower
um but I I found a win that's really all
that matters definitely okay
congratulations that was an absolutely
thrilling Armageddon to watch and I have
to ask you about that first game against
Wesley the very last moment when you
moved that King to F7 what happened that
just take us through that uh that
situation
I mean the thing is initially I didn't
realize that he could trade the Queens
there was there was another variation
where I think the Queens get traded on
like E6 I win the e-pawn but he can go
like King G3 and F4 and that's winning
and so initially I didn't realize that
that that existed and I spot it but then
later as as we're getting along time I
mean I just played King F7 because I was
sure Queen E6 was the only move I just
for some reason I just thought Queen F3
I go Queen F6 trade King takes King E5
and I'm I'm just winning so I win the
pawn but with the double pawns on the B
file it's actually losing and yeah I
think pretty much as soon as I played it
he moved instantly so I didn't quite I
didn't like quite have time for it to
register until after the draw uh
occurred but I did in that Split Second
I kind of did realize that it was a
mistake but you know it is what it is
and obviously it's a bit of a miracle
but that's how it goes when something
sorry you gotta when something like that
happens do you also think that shifts
the momentum for you in a way that
Wesley realizes he had this huge
opportunity to take a match lead but
failed to do so in that critical moment
yeah I mean of course if you miss a win
and one where there's no counter play
where you just trade into a king upon
end game which you're gonna win 100 of
the time I mean it's it is somewhat
devastating I mean that being said it's
very tricky too because after that I
wasn't sure if I should just make the
drawer if I should actually try to beat
him because Wesley obviously was
frustrated I could see it on his face
and and so I had a decision too but I
figured at the end of the day um you
know I'd rather flip coins and hopefully
hopefully it comes with pads more times
than it comes up tells and the Hikaru
Festival congratulations uh looking
forward to tomorrow you're playing
Magnus at least once maybe even two
matches what's your strategy going to be
like as you aim for Revenge
um you know I I don't know I I I feel
like uh the the two the two matches that
I played against Mac is this one and
also the the famous one back in 2020
where we played over seven days which
was also rather fittingly uh decided by
an arm again you know I think I mean
we're both both very good players
um I mean if there's anything maybe I'll
play more with more risk because I do
have twin two matches you know for
example say we get to an Armageddon
tomorrow and I win that arm again I
still to win another match it's not as
simple as winning one match so I mean
maybe I'll take more risks it's hard to
know but uh it's always good to to be in
the finals and it's always fun to play
against Magnus um you know we've played
a lot over the years and um he's the
best of the best so you want if you want
to win you have to beat the best and
that's that's how I view it yeah Hikaru
the chat has been asking this question a
lot we asked Magnus yesterday so I have
to ask you which Pokemon is your
favorite
I mean I've never reply I've never I've
never played Pokemon it's just not my
thing so you know I'm more of an old
school guy I played like the OG games
you know the things like Diablo Warcraft
Starcraft like the real OG games not as
new age hippie stuff
very cool and uh well we're all looking
forward to your match against Magnus
tomorrow you're still unbeaten in the
air things monsters how happy are you
with the way you're playing
you know that that's actually an
interesting question you know more more
broadly speaking it's not not even so
much about this about about this event
but when you think about tournaments I
mean the the classic question that you
can ask top players is you know if you
play two games and you draw two games is
that better than winning a game and
losing a game and most players would say
that two draws is better
um and in a match format certainly it's
much more important to not lose games
when I just say win a game and lose the
game
um so it's definitely benefited me being
very solid but at the same time I mean
the drawback is when you play and say
Swiss tournaments like the world Blitz
or the world rap and you have to win a
lot of games you know if you draw Too
Many Games bad things happen so I'm
happy that I've gone undefeated I mean
against Wesley I've had a couple of bad
bad positions against Magnus in the
first game probably I was losing at one
moment so even though even though I
haven't lost game it hasn't been like
super solid so I'm someone pleased with
my play but there's definitely room for
improvement
wow we're all so excited and now it's
been a treat to watch you in this
tournament so far and tomorrow is such a
big day for all of us and for the chess
fans so I just want to look ahead a
little more that on that with you and
just just own words what do you think
that in this format what is it that
Magnus perhaps does better than you and
what is it that you do better than
Magnus
I mean Magnus is uh much better getting
winning positions and converting them
that's a simple simple answer I mean I
haven't really had many opportunities I
mean I don't think I've had any real
opportunities to win win a game since uh
the first day when I played against goo
cash
um so he's very good at converting I'm
very good at defending and hanging on um
for a long time I mean those I think
that's the biggest difference between us
certainly again you know as far as the
individual match yesterday I mean Magnus
had some chances third game maybe for
like a move or two I had some chances
but uh you know it came down to
Armageddon and that that's that's how it
goes I mean could you really say that I
was better than Wesley in either of
these matches I don't I don't know if
you could even really say that I mean I
think Wesley was just as good as me it's
just that I got black in the critical
game and he wasn't able to beat me in
either of the two matches so I I think
it's I think the edges are very very
small and I mean I think we're both
great competitors and hopefully uh
hopefully tomorrow tomorrow will be fun
yeah are you enjoying this format uh
Hikaru with Dublin elimination match
format Armageddon bidding everything
going on
yeah I mean I I think uh I mean to be
truthful I have to like the format
because honestly for the stronger
players double elimination is better I
mean for someone like Wesley for example
you know after he lost maybe he was done
he's done but he had a chance to come
back had a chance to win today
um so if I'm being truthful double
elimination definitely favors the
stronger players uh because because they
have to have two bad days as opposed to
one bad day
um so I you know in general it's very
good for me uh I think for the fans
though it's also quite exciting because
when you know if somebody has a bad day
like goo catch for example against me I
mean he just was completely out of form
lost two games and it's all over right
there basically
um but he has a chance to come back so I
think I think that that's helpful and
then also the fact that someone can lose
a match and win win two two matches
tomorrow to win the whole thing I I like
it I think I think it's good overall and
of course it benefits me so I mean of
course of course it's good yeah
hey girl we appreciate you talking to us
and we wish you best of luck in the
grand final tomorrow
thank you so much you guys all the best
all of us tomorrow hikara Nakamura
against Magnus Carlson tomorrow but what
a fight it was between Hikaru and Wesley
So today we're also joined by Wesley
playing two matches today now knocked
out of the air things monsters how are
you Wesley
not very good
it was a very close
that's yeah definitely what what uh what
happened there in the end in the
Armageddon
yeah I think I let's just uh slower I I
didn't
I didn't have good nerves in the end
like I knew I had very good chances to
win and I thought it was going to but
you know I just uh
I just played to immediately and also
like my nerves didn't keep up in the
crucial moments and I was looking at my
club you know he cares clearly faster
also in the Armageddon without any
increment even if you get the winning
position you have to be very careful not
flag so I was keeping an eye on that and
then uh I didn't work out and then on
move
I'll try to TradeWinds because I was
pretty sure that if the queen were
traded that the end game is pretty
straightforward winning and I thought we
make Windows on D6 you know it was
pretty clinical
but um
the problem is you basically get a
winning position against Ricardo who
just never gives up and take it he keeps
he keeps defending extremely well like
you know I think anyone else would have
lost that position upon down with the
opposite called Bishops but
uh hegar would just defended extremely
well then I blundered and wolf played it
too yeah but I I think I think like when
he played Bishop B5 I think I should
just take the a pawn B takes A4 then A5
and I was regretting not playing that
like I'm two points up and
at least I have a path compared to
compared to the game then definitely try
to push my pawns on the king side but I
waited too long like uh I I both want to
go this F3 G4 try to attack his King but
I just played it the worst possible
moment but with two minutes with three
minutes on the clock it's not and no
increment it's not so so easy for for
your nerves yeah
we did see uh some big smiles on your
face when the beds came in what was your
reaction to tomorrow going as low as
eight minutes and five seconds
yeah that was pretty shocking I
because I think it's insane to go that
low like I we we had this building Wars
starting last year for the global Chess
Championship and back then players were
beating extremely high like 12 minutes
and against Jefferson I bid 11 minutes
and it's just insane that anyone would
go it but it did eight minutes and eight
minutes and five yeah
yeah I mean it's totally insane because
if you think about it normal Armageddon
is five minutes for white and four four
black
so then if white has 10 minutes then
it's eight minutes like in stop hunger I
think it's 10 versus 7.
but and so you think that I get 15
minutes you need at least nine minutes
or nine and a half but
or even 10 minutes but it's just totally
insane that anyone would go that low
like I was pretty sure that I would get
the black Pieces by beating 829 and I'm
not sure if it's a good idea but I
wanted to try black for the last game
and see how it goes but I mean if you
bid eight minutes then you're clearly
gonna win like I'm not sure it's a it's
a great idea honestly
uh but uh
uh you know hiker was pretty confident
to do that like
eightness is just so little time like
your opponent can basically try to try
to Sag you as long as uh he gets a game
and yeah as as long as you're compared
to the equal strength so that's why I'm
very happy when I won the extra pawn and
in the opening I think uh it's funny
Hikaru just played Knight D5 clearly I
think he makes a piss opening line like
he was just playing quickly
so it's that's totally insane of course
but I mean big congratulations to uh
Hikaru for winning twice against me and
uh you know I I think that they had I
was playing well like I had very good
chances to to win this match uh but my
nerves wasn't able to keep up with with
my play yeah the Wesley I feel guilty
bringing this up now but we did see a
big reaction uh from Hikaru after game
one of your match uh on the final move
yeah you checked afterwards did you
realize that there was a win there just
on the final move
uh yeah I didn't realize that the final
move was winning but I was winning
before that
uh so
you know I was very happy to play B5
also on move 32 hold 33. uh he made the
blunder with King H7 when he should like
win F4 and black probably hold the door
but when he played dh7
uh instead of trading Rooks I could just
play Rook E6
and it's basically completely winning
for quite intellect plus four
um but also on move 36
uh if you when you play G5 which was a
blender like I actually just play Queen
E6 and I was thinking about this move
like we need six
and if he doesn't trade Queen if you
play Queen f8 then there's Queen G6 and
he's he loses his King side Pawns
because his King is tough meanwhile if
he trades wins with Big Sticks King G7
then the pawn end game is Just winning
after F4
or or even I guess it Ginger to an F4 so
I was spending some time thinking about
Queen E6
but unfortunately I didn't play that so
I was winning at some point at certain
points like more than once
um
so yeah things would have been much
different uh
but that's a Pity yeah but you've had a
huge uh tournament Wesley almost
unbeaten I can see you're sitting inside
with a jacket it's a very cold in
Minnesota where you are right now
yeah I guess I guess uh
well it's getting warmer I I guess yeah
I'm a little bit superstitious that way
I mean been
uh wearing the same jacket since uh day
one like maybe I should change to a
better jacket but I didn't want to
change anything and I didn't think I'd
reached this this far the tournament so
uh
it's nice and uh
and you know we're leaving tomorrow so I
thought I wouldn't change anything but
uh
yeah it's been super enjoyable to watch
you play here and there things monsters
and we're super excited because we
definitely will see you in division one
also in the next event
yeah I mean that was my main plan for
today to at least qualify for tomorrow
because it would be nice to meet the
girl but at the same time then I play
Magnus tomorrow and
uh maybe he has a better chance than
than me and uh yeah again yeah we
congratulations to Hikaru with a nice
defense and uh hopefully he he
feels better regarding his family issues
right now
Wesley thank you so much for all the
entertainment and I will see you again
in the next event thank you also for
joining us
yeah I'm very excited to join now I'm
going to have to prepare for classical
tournaments thank you guys thank you so
much Wesley it takes uh third place
Wesley so in the air things Masters uh
what a player losing only one game it's
been incredible for Wesley so as well he
was in fantastic form and the way he
played the games he had the advantages
on the board against the car knock more
but he just couldn't put him away and
he's so humble he has so much respect
for his opponent he's always trying to
be objective and I just wonder if he
lost that objectivity for a second down
the stretch of that Armageddon game
maybe he could have flagged takaru he
just had to throw away the actual
evaluation function and just focus on
the clock yeah all right let's take a
look at the bracket we only have one day
and one potentially two matches left in
the air things monsters Magnus Carlsen
he won the winners final yesterday
against Hikaru Nakamura so it's been a
day off today for Magnus Carlsen he will
play in the the grand final tomorrow to
face now Hikaru Nakamura another big
match between these two it's gonna be
best out of four rapid games with
Armageddon tie breaks if they are tied
if Hikaru Nakamura wins that match then
the Grand Final will go to a reset
because that means Magnus Carlsen will
also have lost a match and the Grand
Final will be decided with a two game
match also again with Armageddon tie
breaks if they are tied what's your
expectations for that David will we see
Magnus win it in the first match or will
we see Hikaru Nakamura get his revenge
I'm not sure what to expect Kyle but I
can't wait just the thought of one match
between them is Juicy enough we already
had that a couple of days ago we're
going to get a second match with them a
third match would be a charity uh and
the icing on the cake so yeah I just
want a full-blooded fight in that one
and may the best man win yeah
potentially they're gonna play six rapid
games and two Armageddon games tomorrow
Tanya it's going to be a long day
probably and that must be exhausting
coming up Madness needs to make sure he
doesn't have any late nights tonight so
that's one thing and you're absolutely
right energy is going to be absolutely
key and I think this is a dream final
this is a this is an absolute dream
final for us for chess fans everywhere
the one thing that when I look back at
their first match in this event is that
perhaps if Hikaru does get the chance
with the white pieces he needs to make
the most of it the strategy of going for
an Armageddon
might work with everyone Under the Sun
but might not be the best bet against
Magnus Carlsen if you've got the white
pieces you need to make the most of it
definitely the Grand Final in division
one is coming up tomorrow the Grand
Final in division two is also coming up
tomorrow but we actually don't know
who's going to play in that yet the only
player we know definitely will play
there is Fabiano cariana he has won the
winners final today but the losers
bracket is still going on in division
two to decide who will face
Ariana tomorrow
in the grand the final in division two
and in division three we already have a
winner the Grand Final was played today
and young Sam Savion is the winner of
bad tea beat
in the Grand Final
what a day what a day it's been we have
one more day in the air things Masters
and today as well we've had a very cool
puzzle Ivanka it's time to reveal the
answer to the puzzle yeah it was a short
and sweet one but it was cute I would
say it's from a study from 1964 by afan
Sega and uh
okay the whole idea is that you know
white is in Dire Straits black porn is
going to promote and there's only one
part of Salvation and also to Victory
and that's just to push the seed Pawn
one square forward trap the king and uh
well people could be asking well why
does that porn just not promote and here
comes the killer thing the night walk
jump to the D6 square and suddenly like
a bolt from the blue you'll realize that
the king is actually trapped now there's
one final trick in this position to see
and that is black could play Queen takes
porn
but this is actually no good because of
night to B7 check and uh suddenly the
queen can be taken the King has to step
away horn takes Queen and that is it the
Knight can step forward and also defend
the bit Pawn on e4 and that is it
beautiful
but simple and those are the puzzles
that I like
definitely beautiful puzzle and uh we
did ask you guys to uh share your
answers on social media and we would
actually pick a winner to get a very
cool prize today Ivanka what is the
price it is a six months a diamond
membership of chess.com and I have to
say this winner has a very cool name
I'm excited to hear it okay it's gobble
squat King oh no this is Joe I'm sorry
John solo Oh no okay John solo like he
gave the most thorough answer actually
uh C3 and there he gives absolutely
every single variation
fantastic wow good job John solo you are
the winner and uh we'll get a very cool
prize we also have a winner uh in our
selfie competition you guys have been so
cool sharing your selfies on Twitter
using the hashtag chess Champs
Carol the seaport is the winner what a
nice uh selfie oops I played the
bonecloud again
might need an air things device to
improve my chest well you're getting one
and everything's device signed by Magnus
Carlsen is coming for you and the find
the Grand Final in the air things
monsters is coming up tomorrow it's
gonna be between the two giants in
online chess minus Carlsen and Hikaru
Nakamura who do you think will win a
tunnel
uh I am just ready for the match I can't
wait for it and I think it was a little
heartbreaking today for Wesley you know
he had his chances he played a brilliant
Armageddon but tomorrow is the big day
we'll have our champion tomorrow and
like I said Kaya this is really a dream
final and I'm so excited for it hard to
pick a favorite we've seen it in this
format Anything Can Happen bring in the
popcorn yeah David
um I'll say Hikari just because it feels
like he can hit another level and I
can't wait to see him try tomorrow nice
and Robert I think David is just taking
that answer because he knows what I was
gonna say it has to say Magnus Carlsen
he has two lives so of course he's the
heavy favorite uh he would be the
favorite even if he just had one but
with two lives of course it's Magnus
Carlsen oh it's gonna be a super
exciting first Grand Final in the 2023
Champions chess tour the Grand Final is
coming up tomorrow between those two
giants so join us for all the action we
could potentially have two
armageddon's coming up tomorrow we'll
see you then have a good night or day
wherever you are in the world in the
meantime bye
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign